digital marketing is an umbrella term
used to market goods or services using
digital technologies such as computers
mobile phones and the internet the
internet has bought with a whole new
change in the way businesses are
marketed digital marketing continues to
grow and evolve with new advances in
technology a lot of people want to learn
digital marketing but they don't know
where to start this tutorial will look
at the basics of digital marketing and
will help you get started with digital
marketing
it will also look at some of the
different things that you can do to get
started with digital marketing
so without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session
firstly we will understand what digital
marketing is then types of digital
marketing and the best digital marketing
tools that you can use
next we will talk about digital
marketing careers jobs resumes and
salaries
then we will look at the skills required
to be a digital marketer and the roles
and responsibilities they have
and then we will wrap up the session
with the discussion of the top 50
digital marketing interview questions
and answers
meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it
first joey learned that digital
marketing was a form of marketing
through which you could advertise to
people digitally digital marketing
leveraged different channels like search
engines websites social media platforms
emails and mobile applications
it would give marketers the opportunity
to interact with and understand their
audience better and to increase the
trust in their rank
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to people based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there were also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with first joey created content
like blogs videos infographics and case
studies so that he could generate
audience interest in the brand's
products or services
this was content marketing
next he needed his audience to actually
see his content the first step was to
create content on specific search
keywords that were relevant to the
target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results
by continuous optimizations joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position
this was seo or search engine
optimization and joey could do all of
this without spending a single penny
he could also drive traffic to the
website with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked he could have text ads that show
up in search engine results image ads
and video ads that show up in websites
and much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing joey
realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
help them better understand the products
they visited on the website and assist
them in the buying process he would also
send emails to advertise his products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although joey was able to grow the
brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third-party websites this could be
achieved with affiliate marketing
affiliates would promote the brand or
product to their audiences for a fee
with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through
the wait
now as we wait for the results let's
take a break and look at a quiz
which one of the following forms of
marketing involves engaging and
nurturing your audience to make sure
they buy your products or services
a seo
b
ppc
c email marketing
d
affiliate marketing let us know your
answer in the comment section below for
a chance to win an amazon voucher
now let's see what happens at the end of
joey's weight
although joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success that's when
joey realized he had to gain more
knowledge and experience
so he decided to get certified and get
ahead in his career with the help of
simplylearn he took up simplylearn's
digital marketing certification and got
the skills and training he needed to
become an expert digital marketer and
now you know where he is
you too can do the same and grow in your
career by clicking on the top right
corner so
today we're going to talk about
why digital marketing is important in
today's world uh we're also going to
talk about what is digital marketing and
the types of digital marketing channels
that are out there then we're going to
talk about the customer life cycle in
digital marketing so what does it take
to get somebody from point a
to point z
through digital marketing and so those
are the topics we're going to cover so
hope you enjoy yourself while you're
learning and let's get right to it so
let's start talking about why digital
marketing is important so let's start
there on the why so
we're just a fly on the wall and we're
in an office environment we're looking
at two friends having a conversation
about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digit marketing has become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise so in response hey
over the past few decades digital
marketing has evolved at a rapid pace
these days a lot of people spend most
their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every 60 seconds so
according to social media today i mean
there's a lot of snaps there's a lot of
clicks there's a lot of text there's a
lot of videos watched there's a lot of
pictures being taken there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure it's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile and with digital marketing
very versatile so again going back to
our flyer printing an eight and a half
by eleven okay that's it you know with
with digital marketing you're running
display banners 468 by 60 200 by 200 250
by 250 300 by 300 i mean the list goes
on on the types of different display
sizes not to mention text ads not to
mention video or multimedia uh so
there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so meaning if you're
trying to get that tv spot there might
not be a spot open until one in the
morning okay well with digital marketing
there is no hours okay you can certainly
get your point out there and have people
see it instantaneously so with
traditional marketing there's a lack of
real-time results i mean this seems like
uh it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant okay nowadays
go to analytics you can look at real
time reporting okay so we could see real
time results okay traditional marketing
can be very costly i mean if you're not
only doing postcards and printing
postcards but you have to mail those
postcards so there's postage fees where
with digital marketing it's very very
very cost efficient i mean meaning you
could pick and choose who you want to
target when you want to target where you
want to target what you want to target
and if you're doing search you can put
your bidding in place you can put your
hours in place you can really control
how much you actually spend so that to
me is one of the biggest advantages to
digital marketing not only do you get
real-time results but you can control
costs and then obviously optimize based
on the amount of cost you're spending
based on those real-time results with
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience i mean you know i don't
want to bash traditional marketing too
much i mean if you're going to put a tv
ad in place you know you're going to do
it on a tv show that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and when
we talk about technology it could be an
app it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo
so seo stands for search engine
optimization there's search engine
marketing there's email marketing
affiliate marketing social content
mobile and then we can get into subsets
of each of these digital marketing
channels but really we'll start with seo
because that's the king and to me that's
basically increasing the quality and
quantity of relevant organic traffic on
the search engines including google so
depending on where you're located in the
u.s market google tends more has a large
market share so you want your pages on
your website to be found and clicked on
organically and so that means that
somebody types in a keyword you want
that relevant page to show up first on
google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're going to
get to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword you don't have to worry
about organic if you're willing to pay
for it you just bid on that keyword and
voila you have the opportunity to appear
number one in the search results at the
top of the page for that keyword now
when somebody clicks on it you have to
pay google if it's google you're
advertising on but that's the beauty of
search engine marketing you can bid on
keywords and appear at the top of the
search results for that keyword example
here if we go back to online shopping
well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from females who
are 35 years of age to 44 that live in
say this southern part of the united
states you can segment that and send
them an email and cater that email
directly to that audience and of course
you can put some nice call to action in
there you could design it really snazzy
and you could track it just like you can
any other digital marketing channel so
email is a very effective way to really
reach a target audience because
everybody for the most part has a
functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase a product and if you purchase
it you're going to get 30 off and you
can put the coupon code right in there
with a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to basically
create a sales force of people so
basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you can
see earn up to 12 advertising fees with
a trusted e-commerce leader
okay so if somebody clicked on that and
purchased for example or joined you
could pay off that commission okay let's
turn our attention to social media
marketing so social media marketing you
know i would say it's fairly new i mean
if i think about it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006 so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you could post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so
if you're trying a targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're gonna post on there so
it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there um and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on youtube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example
you can use basically sms or instant
messaging via mobile devices to promote
your product or service here's another
example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want a net we want we know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's what we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
life cycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling or
what we're promoting okay so the
awareness stage is really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
going to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does a customer need it
and what solution does it provide those
are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is it gonna help
me in my life okay and who who is
selling this i mean who is this brand i
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see it when they
do a search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority
in the awareness stage display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found and so to me this is you
know where the blog comes in seo take
that content get it optimized okay sem
if we're not ranking organically we can
make sure we're at the top of the paid
search results or the the search results
for a particular keyword we want to be
found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you can still get traffic from mobile or
email so now that we got the word out
via all these different marketing
channels there's that consideration
stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you gonna stand out and then how will i
increase customer engagement towards my
product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer those questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with the promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware you
know you can really hone in
and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remarket to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
here okay so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that okay so
with mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so
remember we want to encourage customers
to buy a product by creating detailed
articles about the product that always
helps and that's content okay we want to
opt for a customer testimonial okay that
helps sway people and add some guest
blogging okay we can have ambassadors
blog on our behalf or we can go out and
blog on somebody else's site okay so
blogging works both ways it's ways of of
showing yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you
and now we're on to the purchase stage
so the questions we want to really make
sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence and make sure you get
people to you know review you or provide
testimonials because people are going to
do their due diligence before they
purchase especially if it's on google my
business or yelp or tripadvisor or
whatever it is you're trying to sell
they're gonna be able to see those
reviews and so do your due diligence to
get the reviews and if it is a negative
review hey that's okay you can't please
everyone you're gonna get them that's
the world we live in just make sure you
show your upper hand and respond even to
the negative as well as the positive
reviews that you get that actually bodes
well to some people because hey it shows
that i made a mistake and you're willing
to correct it and so people actually see
that that could be the tipping point to
getting them to purchase hey look hey
this brand really cares because they're
really responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to econsultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
could mean providing a promo giving them
that extra incentive you know if you
don't offer promo consider it especially
on the email and the example we looked
at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to and
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20 percent and email's a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of people through sms okay social media
reaching people instantaneously and then
you know really with the purchase stage
it gives pro prospects an offer to help
them make that purchase so you have
plenty of channels to choose from in
fact most of these channels the only one
really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to not push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer review and if they don't give you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media
you know you can thank your community
for supporting you on this recent
campaign that you ran you know even
throwing an extra five or ten percent on
a future purchase is a thank you and
that's easily done on social media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting
you know the success of a product and
then offering a promotion okay so
there's a lot of things you could be
doing here on the post purchasing stage
so to me even looking at content again
you could even you know put a survey
together you could even put a survey
together for your affiliates okay you
could even post a poll on facebook so
it's just working in with these
different channels to get some feedback
about your product and service so with
email mobile you can engage customers
with follow-up emails or customer care
content you know with mobile if you have
somebody's mobile number hey text them a
simple thank you goes a long way you
know you could say hey look if you're
satisfied let us know give us a call you
can even in the ee mobile text message
you can put a link to a survey send
emails to active subscribers give
rewards for customer feedback so if
somebody does provide feedback give them
an extra 10 off you know you want to be
able to reward loyalty loyalty comes in
the form of a partnership if you're
giving somebody discounts and you have a
good product or service then they're
going to recognize that they're going to
say hey look i really like this product
and they're giving me 10 i'm going to go
ahead and purchase from these guys again
so give those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site you know reward them or if
it's an email and you put a four to a
friend get an extra 10 off it doesn't
hurt because you're incentivizing people
to help you sell your product so with
social display and content use those
banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms
to also enhance uh what they purchased
so hey you just purchased this product
thank you very much did you know you
could do this this and this with it and
so that's the idea of a post-purchase
stage is to maximize these channels to
be able to answer those essential
questions about what else could they
purchase you know do they like how do i
get these people to become loyal
customers okay so with the first
purchase stage if a customer has bought
a pair of sports shoes for example
running shoes you can recommend cross
product sale a cross sale it could be a
pair of shorts or a water bottle or an
accessory with an exclusive discount so
that's another example what you can do
on the post purchase stage so what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
look at some of the
best digital marketing tools for not
only 2019
but ones that have performed well in the
past that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future so past present and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this uh with a good focus on a
lot of different marketing channels here
so we're going to focus first on seo
talk about some of the tools related to
on page and off page we're going to
switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it
in fact if there's a tool that we didn't
mention in today's webinar feel free to
mention it in the comment box below this
video we'd love to hear what you're
using to manage your particular digital
marketing channel okay and so the goal
for today's webinar is hey we hope you
get something out of this in terms of
using new tools there's some tools that
i use some tools that my colleagues use
everybody uses different tools so it'd
be good to kind of see what else is out
there so if you have something to share
share it by all means what we're trying
to do is share what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're gonna do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization or organic
search we have a mixture of paid and
free so there's a lot of different
platforms but if you're focusing on seo
you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's semrush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about seo you'll know
that using google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another seo
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on but this is just a
small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and
google's keyword planner helps us hone
in on keywords we may be interested in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're gonna have
high volume and low competition so let's
take a look at an example in google's
keyword planner so here i am i'm in
google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here meal delivery so we're
going to just type in mail delivery and
get some results so notice i can enter a
domain as a filter and so in other words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another key to it if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on
if mail delivery is my business and so
let's just hone in on that one keyword
mail delivery we want to be found
organically for that keyword so what
google
keyword planner does is not only give us
the keyword and other keywords relevant
to that but it gives us the average
monthly search volumes and this is an
average over the course of the last 12
months and notice here i get a column
for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
7.46
and at the top of the page high range
16.61 cents so
that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna try and optimize for
this keyword i know it's competitive
because not only google is telling me
it's competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of google so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner and
note that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer or shorter period of time
you can even choose a specific location
so i chose texas i can certainly choose
the entire united states to get a sense
of what the volume would be for the
total u.s so you have settings that you
can change and manipulate to get you
the data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords
high volume low competition now
alternatively
i can certainly use another tool to find
keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask moz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from 11
and a half thousand to 30 000 on monthly
volume now what moz does is they give
you a difficulty score so a difficulty
score is a score between 1 and 100 and
so i could see this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's if it's a hundred it's
very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
google ads you can always use mazda
remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
could sign up for a free account and you
could sign up for a free account as a
test trial and you could test it for a
period of days and leverage its tools
during that free trial to get a better
sense of how these tools work so we want
to be able to use mods we want to be
able to use google's keyword planner not
only to search for all those relevant
keywords available to you but we want to
be able to choose keywords with high
volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice portfolio of diverse relevant
keywords with high search volume and low
difficulty and then you want to be able
to identify those keywords that your
competitors are ranking for so moz gives
you that information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this we got a nice
webinar on keyword research for seo so
take a look at that video on youtube and
to get more specific details about using
seo tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
seo so let's talk about some other
reasons under seo what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic
hrefs again moz let's take a look at
google search console and i want to hone
in on google search console because it
is free and it's a must if you're going
to work on seo you need to be working in
google search console and so the whole
key behind google search console is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified when
school can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see
some important information so here i'm
looking at a website and what am i
looking at i'm looking at something
called coverage under index so what does
coverage mean well going back to what we
just said we want to be able to
understand how google's crawling and
indexing our pages and so what google
does is through this platform search
console is they're letting us know once
they go to our website and start
crawling it and they pull these pages
back to their server they're letting us
know
if we actually have any issues so here i
could see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a 4
4
you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i could
see submitted url marked no index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you know fall victim to this error
and so we can really hone in
on what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i can see
they've certainly were able to crawl and
index
9115 pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54 000 plus pages and
then we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they discovered via the sitemap
and so the whole point of a site map is
we want to be able to get and push the
urls to google not have google come to
our site and discover them so this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with google all the urls
that you have on your site that you want
google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report so google is a
staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish
a lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior
on mobile so they begin it on mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today
starts with mobile so they want you to
understand how your site fares via
mobile and when i say fares via mobile
is it mobile friendly is it responsive
is it loading quick enough you know is
it formatted to google standards and so
if there are any issues google's going
to let you know what those issues are so
here i could see google's recognized 206
pages before different issues okay so
here i can see what those issues are
just like the coverage issues we can see
specifically what they are and so here i
can see for 206 pages text too small to
read
click elements too close together the
viewport not set to device width and
then content wider than the screen so
there's 10 pages that fit under this
error and if i actually click on it the
error i can see what those 10 pages are
and so when we're done we can actually
when we address the issues we can
actually have google validate whether
the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with google
telling google look i see what the
issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey
we do recognize the errors we are fixing
the errors please validate them you know
it's going to draw google's attention
google's going to validate them and get
these pages indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or maybe of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search consoles shows
us what pages have the most links okay
so here we can see the home page has 26
000 plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so
externally i want links from other
websites pointing to various pages on my
site and i certainly want my pages
linking to one another on my site and so
i'll be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using google
search consoles links report okay
there's one more report that i think's
of interest in google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with google
analytics so you can see the same report
and analytics if you're able to link up
google search console with analytics and
you should be able to do that all you
need to do is make sure you use the same
email address that you use for analytics
and search console so it needs to be the
same email address you could certainly
link up the two and have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
google so when they're typing them into
google
we can actually see how many impressions
the keyword queries received and how
many clicks the keyword queries received
and then i can see click-through rate
and average position okay so here i can
see
for this particular keyword on the first
line i could see over the course of the
last three months it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the
209 000 297
into the 120 000 397 okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you a click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57 so
over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many impressions and
clicks i'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
i can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now i
mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so i could
see the same data that i see in search
console but this time i'm looking at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my impressions my click-through rate
bike search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and nofollow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report
we can identify top performing gaining
and losing keywords again the
performance report so we could certainly
look at the google search console report
but if you have a platform like moz you
can certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on page
optimization but for off page
optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example
i'm just going to type in this domain
i'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain authority so a score out
of 1 in 100 i'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if i click on the linking domains i'm
going to be actually able to see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazda even takes it a
step further they also give me a spam
score so moz is able to measure how
spammy a website is so if i have a
combination of say a low domain
authority and a high spam score then i
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so i can use this report
here you can see here as i keep going
down for example i could see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a spam score
of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's like
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority spam etc
everything you need to use in order to
measure off page seo so that's the great
thing about moz is they have not only
on-page seo tools but off-page seo tools
and moz is a freemium so to speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for seo but also for local seo
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so i use and lean on moz a lot for
all that it has to offer from choosing
keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mall with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos
and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner uh moz and google search console
okay let's switch over to email
marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version whenever you say
freemium meaning they have a free trial
available then you're expected to
upgrade but you know mailchimp to me is
a tool i use i like the interface very
easy for beginners so we're going to
take a look at mailchimp but there are
certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marcato is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma
you know feel free to to note that in
the comment section below this video i'm
curious as to how many people actually
use you know different tools because
there are so literally so many email
marketing tools out there why because
email marketing has been around probably
the longest amongst all the other
digital marketing channels and a lot of
people use email on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you can certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around
that particular audience so you know you
have a good tool when you can do that
when you can really segment for your
audience okay you want to be able to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to
manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time and day so these tools also allow
you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multi-variant
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly
design the email so if we click design
email again this is important because
with email marketing you want to be able
to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer so you know here you can see
there's some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
lists
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so here i could see
this email that was sent out in june i
could see it was sent to 95 000 plus
subscribers okay of the subscribers i
saw 2 000 plus open it and 157 clicks so
i can view this report in more detail
just by clicking on view report so again
we want an email platform that's going
to be able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so i can get down
really to the nitty-gritty i can
actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here i'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16
percent i only had an open rate of 2.5
so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with a
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products
and somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the car
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience
you can manage your audience list and
you can get detailed reporting on your
different campaigns for that audience so
that's mailchimp and summary and so most
email platforms do a lot of similar
features or have some of the similar
features but that's what you ideally
want to look for in an email marketing
platform so here's a tool that doesn't
get talked about enough when it comes to
email marketing and that's google's url
builder and the reason why we're going
to talk about this tool today is because
most people in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics
is it allows you to track different
campaigns so if you're doing
pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters so the
first one is campaign source so what's
the source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify
male champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lowercase so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or you know some of
these other one convertkit then go ahead
and put in that platform as the source
now for the medium which is the means in
which we're driving traffic to the site
let's go ahead and put in email because
that's what we're using to drive traffic
to this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients i want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's gonna get
subject line one and one segment that's
gonna get subject line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is in the campaign
content field so now i have four
parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised or appended url so my original
url was visit florida.com
ian-us
florida-beaches.html my original url
i've now appended that with some utm
parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with my utm parameters appended to the
url so that's for the first subject line
that's for the audience that's going to
get the first subject line i want to do
another one for the second subject line
so now i'm going to change my campaign
content parameter to subject line
underscore 2. i'm going to copy that url
i'm going to check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do i'm going to use
the first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line two so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm going to use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
sent out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm going to look for in google
analytics so we can start with source
and medium so if i click on source and
medium as my primary dimension here i
can see
mailchimp and the actual date was used
as part of the variable for for source
and then i will can i see the medium
being email so now i can see for this
email that was sent out in mailchimp in
may
i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder
again you're taking a url that you're
going to use in email and then you're
going to pan that url with different
parameters campaign source campaign
medium campaign name and then optionally
campaign content or campaign term okay
once you've entered variables into those
parameters you're going to get an
appended url which you can then use in
your email so when the email gets sent
you're going to go back over to google
analytics and you're going to look at
the results of that campaign of that
source of that medium of that content
i.e subject line and so that's why
the url builder is so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but
what we really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools
kind of the central focal point of all
digital marketing and it starts really
with google analytics google analytics
is a freemium meaning that they have a
free version that you can use there is
also a paid version of google analytics
but given the advent of google its
popularity especially in the united
states a majority of users are using the
free version of google analytics so it's
a very popular tool especially for
marketers but there are also other tools
available so it's not just google so we
have adobe analytics which is also
freemium you have kiss metrics you have
spring metrics you have youtube
analytics which is
part of google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well
again we want to really measure behavior
we want to measure what's going on with
our website so we want to be able to
identify the location of where our
website visitors are coming from and a
lot of these analytics tools use
ipaddress to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
fifty percent new and fifty percent
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around
and improve performance so if your
bounce rate is high well how do you
lower bounce rate well we need to do
something about that an analytics tools
will help us identify what's not working
from our site perspective and from a
channel perspective and we can take
action to improve performance so that's
the whole idea behind optimizing our
site's performance so let's jump into
google analytics and let's take a look
at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion and that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
san francisco california came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and
they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i go
to demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 percent of
my traffic and again this is year to
date that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so
i'm painting a picture about you know
gender and age coming to my website well
i can also look at geo so where
specifically might these people be
coming from so if i go to location under
geo i'm going to be able to see a
breakdown of country or i can even hone
it down to city
or specific location and here i could
see united states is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the us
and then 16 from argentina 13 from
mexico 10 from india so we have a nice
mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device
are they using a tablet and so google
analytics breaks it down very nice for
you and so we could see percentages and
actual numbers by device category and so
in this case i could see year to date i
can see 62 percent are coming from
desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic when this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels now analytics allows
you to look at a specific source and
medium so the source would be the actual
website or search engine and the medium
would differentiate how
that traffic actually got to the site so
if we're talking about a search engine
did they come to the site via paid
search or did they come to the site via
organic search and so all we need to do
is change our primary dimension from
default channel grouping to source and
medium and we could see specifically the
breakout of the different sources and
mediums driving traffic to the site so
here i can see google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
could see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources and mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via
source and medium and if you're running
google ads under acquisition analytics
has a whole section of google ads
reporting so if you're running campaigns
on google ads remember we looked at the
keyword planner in google ads so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
you can certainly see the performance of
those campaigns just by clicking on
campaigns we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns
all campaigns and we'll be able to see
the campaign performance if we look at
source and media we'll be able to see
what campaigns
drove traffic to the website so here i
can see
vertical response email as
a driver of traffic so that's the
campaign reporting and then also if you
have search consoles so we looked at
search console earlier we talked about
seo tools well remember i said you can
link up search console with google
analytics well here's search console and
we could see queries devices landing
pages countries so all the performance
metrics that we could see in search
console because we have it linked up
with analytics we can see it right here
so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're going to get so that's
the idea behind it we want to make sure
that we're ranking for our coveted
keywords and if we are we want to be
able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
google search console and google ads you
can connect them directly to google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in behavior we have
a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique page use which
is equal to sessions
so i could have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session i could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and i can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so i can
also see percentage of exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page now
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so when we load up the
speed suggestions report what google
does is say hey we know that this page
is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see
if i scroll down this is desktop and
these are some of the opportunities that
i can address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift and page load time
we see lift and page load time we're
going to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example i can see on line six video i
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video start okay so over this
period of time i could see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always
revert to label and that'll tell you
what page people watched in this case
the video so event tracking is important
because we want to be able to measure
engagement so if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so what you want to
do is you want to be able to set up your
events through google tag manager which
is another google platform but you
certainly want to do that so that's
where you set up your events when you
set up your events for your website with
a category an action and label you'll be
able to measure those events in
analytics under behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so i'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a pdf
submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because we want to be able to
measure conversions on a website so
analytics has four types of conversions
so if i go to admin down at the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have four different types of goals
that i can use now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if i
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it i can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation
then analytics is going to fire that
goal as a conversion and we're gonna see
a conversion against a different metric
or different dimension like channel or
audience okay so destination is the
second type of goal the third type of
goal is duration so how long did
somebody stay on my website so in this
example if they stayed at least one
minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i can see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold types so remember the only goals i
have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter signups
156 donate click buttons i have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the donate now button
i could see that i could see
year-to-date ten thousand eight hundred
eighty-seven users which meant 11 000
sessions 76 clicked on that donate now
button and that comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign mobile
device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see i'm in youtube all i did was i
went to my account then i went to the
beta the studio version of youtube and
then from there i went to analytics so
my account youtube studio analytics and
analytics here is going to give me all
sorts of information about my videos
okay so here i can see over the last 28
days my videos produced over 8 600 views
my watch time in minutes totaled over 17
000
and
i've netted 48 subscribers and this is
an overall okay so i can actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published and here i'm
looking at you know total views over
this particular date range i can also
see specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly
look at some other information if i
click on reach viewers i could see the
total impression so how many times my
video was viewed or how many people
looked at it okay and then the
click-through rate so here i could see
the different traffic sources so 29 came
externally okay here i could see 25 came
within youtube itself i could see how
many times a video was viewed and played
via playlist via suggested videos so i
could see different ways in which the
traffic found my video and actually
watched it here i could see externally
how people were able to find my videos
and i could see 46 percent found it via
google search see some lots of
information here
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos so i could see then
once the traffic found my videos how
many times they actually saw it and
viewed it and then watched it so that's
how many times i was able to reach
viewers via different sources and then
their reaction to that how many times i
saw it and watched it here i can click
on interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partners playlist
was the top playlist so i can see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
youtube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here i could see 88
percent of the people who watched my
videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you wanna hone in on
how your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition is
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool social blade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well
moz we looked at moz earlier for keyword
and organic moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simplylearn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in their ranking so the reason
why we have this is the top bullet point
is because seo organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very technical and creative
there's a lot going on with seo a lot
going on and
sometimes it takes a long time to rank
for something and a lot of seo does
depend on relevancy relevancy being how
many quality backlinks are linked to you
so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you stack up and so that's why
this is up there as number one we want
to be able to
really take a look at what our
competitors are doing another example
would be hey how much uh traffic a
competitors gaining on certain keywords
this could go either way for paid search
organic search what are competitors
bidding on are they really getting
traffic from those keywords so there are
tools out there that help us leverage
what our competition is doing okay we
can also identify our competitors top
performing content for relevant topics
okay we can determine what our
competitor's website referral traffic is
okay we can pull our competitors data
and compare it with our own campaigns so
lots of tools out there to help you do
this and we may want to track the total
amount of clicks a competitor receives
and how much they pay for each keyword
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
few examples how we can leverage all
these bullet points that we just
discussed and so we're going to start
out with
sprout social and sprout social is a
tool i use it's a social media platform
there's a lot of things you can do with
sprout social definitely generate
reports for your social media platforms
you could set up posts that get
published at a certain time and day but
there's also one particular tool in here
called listening and so what we could do
is we just put in for example rv rentals
in twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about rv rentals so we could do
this for twitter we could do it facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword rv rentals now if i
want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand names
or rv share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting to or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay i can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
i can scroll down and i can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and i can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so
to me it just gives me a sense in this
particular example on twitter as to what
are competitors doing okay let's turn
our attention to seo so remember that
first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so moz
has a great tool called link explorer
and link explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain i can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a
comparison across my domain and my
competitors domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has a another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors
really have a number of them i want to
get ready and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so i can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then i can find
opportunities and so just click on
opportunities and you can see
where
my site intersects with their links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then i have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is in moz it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is a report
under moz's link explorer and the
discovered and lost report so we could
put in our domain or we could put even
our competitors domain in there and with
what the page and domain authority is so
this gives me a really really good
insight on all the backlinking that my
competitor has and again if i'm trying
to catch my competitor it's probably not
a bad idea to look at what they're doing
and even copy what they're doing in
terms of backlinking so if we're not on
reddit then we probably need to be on
reddit because if that's where our
competitor is and they're getting good
link juice from reddit which has a
domain authority of 90 then hey if it's
good for the goose it's good for the
ganders so they say so
inbound links is just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitor's doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay i can see
here the keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so this particular domain has been
around a long time okay so that's on the
organic side i can flip over to the paid
side and i could see that they are doing
paid search i could see 5 000 plus
keywords they're bidding on okay based
on that what they're actually paying and
then i could see you know some of the
other competitors listed here from a
paid perspective and an organic
perspective i could see the shared
keyword overlap okay now again you can
pay for this because it's freemium and
get some really good insights as to how
your domain compares to your competitors
so i'm using the free version and here
the free version spyfu is just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
i entered in and so i entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at google ads history i could
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then i can see some organic ranking
history here as i keep scrolling down
this overview report so i can see for rv
rent where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic-wise and so spy food
is a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if i hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and i hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that i get then i could see hey
analytics in this case in this example
i'm sharing
863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and i can compare those web
properties against my own so for all in
the same industry it gives me a sense
here as to how i stack up against the
industry as a whole in this case as it
pertains to channels so you can see here
red not good green is good so in the
industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and
we can adjust our locale and if we do
that google google's going to be able to
adjust how many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and we're going
to go with 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some
good insight as to what the competitors
are doing and you don't want to use a
tool well look no further you can always
go to google.com okay so this is how we
used to do it back in the day before all
these tools became available you just
typed in a keyword and we're going to
type in rv rentals and now we're going
to be able to see who's bidding on that
keyword so we could see we have a number
of different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here i
can see some featured snippets okay and
then i can see some organic search
results okay if i scroll down i'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they're
paying for rv rental so if i clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now i could see i have 163 000 results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have 163 000 different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a 100 impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position i can see how often
i overlap with my competitors okay i
could see how often i'm above a
particular competitor i could see what
percentage i'm at the top of the page
versus my competitors the absolute top
of page rate and then i can see how
often i outrank my competitors and vice
versa how often my competitors outrank
me so i can see all this good insight as
to what competitors are bidding on the
same keywords i am okay so this is if
you're running google ads okay so if
you're running google ads okay you can
just click on the auction insights
report you can find that at the top
navigation just by clicking on campaigns
and by doing so you'll be able to gain
some insights as to where you stack up
from a paid search perspective against
your competitors so let's turn our
attention to paid marketing tools so if
you're doing some advertising on google
bing linkedin you probably want to work
within those platforms
as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search on
say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so
wordstream is a third-party tool that
you can leverage bing and google are
actual advertising network so you would
advertise on the platform itself and get
all the data you need right in the
platform and leverage a lot of the tools
that they have available in the platform
as i mentioned you could also use google
ads editor so bing also has their own
editor as well so and as well as
facebook so you can use an editor type
version and i'll show you that here in a
couple minutes but let's talk about why
we want to use the tools in the platform
itself well we want to be able to
monitor how our ads performing so which
ad receives the most traffic as an
example we want to identify keywords
that are performing for us okay so our
keywords converting not converting now
they cost us a lot of money and not
netting a high enough return for us so
we want to keep an eye on that okay so
we want to monitor our cost okay across
different locations and devices not only
cost but we want to also monitor how our
ads are performing across different
locations of devices keywords across
different locations and devices so we
want to be able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information
in the case of auction insights as to
how
your competitors are performing against
you on google search so
that's on the paid search side then you
have display okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example admiral okay of courtillo
celtra is another paid version of or
paid tool you can use in wide orbit so
these are some of the paid marketing
tools you can leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and right customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side and if we look at social okay why
what tools can we use on social well you
got facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso choir tweepy you got all these
cool paid search tools again i usually
stick with where i'm advertising so if
i'm advertising on linkedin or twitter
i'm gonna leverage that platform but
just know that there are
other tools available for you so with
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so
for these some of the tools like on
facebook we can review and relaunch our
ad campaigns based on target audience we
can measure conversions and gain
insights in this example about facebook
users how are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly so let's jump right into
google ads and look at some tools
available to us
from the search side of the house so for
running search campaigns right in google
ads we could see campaign data we could
see keyword data we could see ad data so
for example if i want to see what ads
are performing i'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads
platform itself now if i want to look at
specific keywords i can do that so i
could see what keywords are driving
traffic and clicks here i could just
sort by clicks and now i can see not
only what keywords are driving clicks i
could see what the click-through rate is
i could see the impressions how many
people actually viewed my ad after click
typing in a keyword query that i'm
bidding on i could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality score
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so
this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some other features available to me here
so here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see a search terms report and
so when it comes to search terms i can
actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query i can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if i see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or i
want my ad shown for
then i can go ahead and just select it
and i can add it as a negative keyword
okay so that tool is available to you
right in google ads okay and then you
have the auction insight so we've
reviewed the auction insights when we're
looking at competitive analysis and so
here if we look at the auction insights
we'll be able to adjust our date range
and we'll be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what their overlap rate is position
above right top of page absolute top of
page right now rank and change so once
we have google has data then they'll be
able to share that information with you
okay so that's just keywords but there's
a cool tool that i really like and i
leverage it for seo and pay-per-click
and that's google's keyword planner so
if you click on tools and then you click
on keyword planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much i
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
i happen to click on that keyword i can
add it to a plan and then once i've
added to a plan then i can go ahead and
look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay so
now once i've added my keyword to that
plan
i can go ahead
and see
how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mention this is one
of our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bit adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i could see the ad
groups here okay so for example i just
want to turn off all these ad groups i
can just highlight them all and just
click status enable to pause and i can
revert back if i want to okay so you can
make household changes so here i could
see at the campaign the ad group level
if i choose an ad group then i can see
some keywords and again i can make
changes at nauseum here i can copy i can
paste i can delete okay so i can make a
lot of changes really quick right in
google as editor and that's the whole
point of editor is to go ahead and work
locally while somebody else is working
locally on the same account you could
both be working
simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so if i say get
recent changes to all campaigns what
google editor is going to do is contact
google ads in the cloud and download all
those changes so here i can see the
changes being download in editor from
google ads and when it's done it's going
to highlight all the changes that have
been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
write an editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
in google ads editor and so that's
google ads editor to me i would
recommend it if you're experienced with
google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on google ads and so
that's google editor ads editor in
summary now let's go back into google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search network as well as for
the display network right in google ads
so if i want to take a look at a
campaign and ad group on the display
network i can just click on that ad
group and i can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the display network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
network you can only use text ads so
here i can look at image ads and i can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click the rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword
ad whatever the dimension is so here on
the display network we can get a sense
of demographics okay so unlike the
search network the display network
allows us to see demographic data and so
now i could see an age breakout or an
age range breakout that google provides
us and i can see again based on the age
range breakout which age range has the
most clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i can see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial
on google ads okay so take a look at the
google ads tutorial we have set up on
youtube okay if you search for google
ads tutorial 2019 this is a good uh
tutorial on everything related to google
ads so check out this video because in
today's webinar we're just mentioning
tools across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do
then you could see just how powerful it
is and all the different features that
are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in google ads so let's move into uh
facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we can see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and then
i can see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so
now i can go in and i can go ahead and
look at the ad performance and go ahead
and change out that ad if it's not
performing to
my expectation so if i click on more
tools and then creatives i can just
simply click on creators and then i can
actually see the create is i actually
have running for that campaign i
selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh reap
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
i can see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then i can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and you know turn
off that particular age and gender if we
needed to and we could see how much we
spent so this just gives you some idea
of the type of reporting that's
available in facebook ads manager now
the great thing about facebook
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup my dimensions if i
needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you can pick and
choose as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to
you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the asset that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want more information
about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial 2019
uh webinar that we did earlier this year
in addition you can also look at another
one that we did on facebook called
facebook advertising tips and strategies
so that should give you some sense of
everything related to facebook ads and
how to take advantage of the facebook
ads manager platform so if there's
anything on social that we may have
missed or that you use feel free to add
a comment below the video we'd love to
hear your feedback okay let's talk about
some affiliate marketing tools let's
turn our attention affiliate marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're going to have to move
on and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are brokers per
se and when i say brokers like for
example with cj you as a merchant or you
as a publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning cj helps
bridge the gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together
and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so cj
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do i mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am i only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
with terms and conditions for say 10 off
all sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites
so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track
certain metrics okay so an affiliate
marketing you have earnings per click
epc as an example most platforms measure
epc from a seven day period to a three
month period okay you can also figure
out what the actual cost per click is
just like you do on say google search
you can actually measure that in
affiliate okay you want to eliminate
fraudulent clicks impressions and
conversions so
any affiliate platform worth its weight
is going to help you understand you know
how many impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product is
somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell the product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher's performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cg.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here
we can't or these publishers can't make
any money if they don't generate clicks
so that's why you have an epc model or
metric so to speak so you can measure
earnings per click cj does it over seven
day period and over a three month period
so you could sort based on seven day or
three month to see who's earning the
most per click in terms of publishers
now you can select under publishers
groups now you can group your publishers
okay so if you have say a group of
publishers in a specific region like the
united states or india or if you're just
focused on the united states and say you
have publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so
here we could see canada and so we have
our publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm gonna repeat it is
you want to get
publishers you want to start building
your base of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's going to buy your product so if
you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here
you you basically a base account and
then uh you can use hootsuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffers a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
decks been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're going to take a look
at that here in a couple minutes okay
and then you got sprout social sprout
social is another social marketing
platform similar to hootsuite do a lot
of reporting a lot of publishing you can
a lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at sprout chelsea today as
well before we do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you could manage
everything one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one twitter account
but multiple twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier
using these social media marketing tools
you want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior then of course monitoring
website traffic and conversion rates
that's key we always want to monitor
conversions based on our kpis our
business goals so there are also a few
important digital marketing tools that
can help you in different ways okay so
without further ado let's jump in and
take a look at what's available in terms
of social media marketing so just a
quick reminder if you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own
metrics if you will so for example
facebook has something called facebook
insight so you'll be able to actually
see you know what's been posted based on
you know the last seven days in this
example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so
i don't have to log into facebook
directly i can see you know the
impressions the engagement the clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth i can see my publishing
behavior how often my publishing i can
see the top post individually i could
see impressions by day you know a lot of
this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose
select a profile write whatever we need
to do you can schedule it for tomorrow
at a specific time and there you go
voila scheduled so this is on twitter
okay so you know we could choose another
platform here it's just that easy to
schedule so
you want to be able to schedule
accordingly because again when you
schedule something then you want to look
at the behavior of it so it's just as
simple as going from publishing to
reporting and then based on when
something got published you could see
the reaction of it and react to it so
another thing here that i like about
it's about social hootsuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being hacked for example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location a radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar spot social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing i like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so i could see
today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account so i can pick and choose the
profile that i want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media libraries the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
can see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i could see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform's
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach a lot profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i wanted to i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtag's been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now i have men's
health but i could type in let's just
say world cup okay so i can see the you
got the cricket world cup you got you
know the soccer football world cup going
on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here i'm following men's
health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that
friday feeling in their tweets and so
the whole idea behind you know tweetdeck
it serves up a interesting overview so
to speak of not only your account but
you know a specific topic or what's
trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social later.com you
know facebook insights so it does cover
in more detail some of what we covered
on these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing tools digital
marketing tools everything from seo to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few
other digital marketing tools that you
can use in different ways like video seo
for example so vid iq you know we want
to use vid iq to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plugin if you
will so i can go and take a look at a
specific specific video and see how many
hours it's been watched how many views
minutes watch subscribers etc you know
the great thing here i can look at the
entire entire account so
i can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third-party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo
then they may pay dividends for you you
want to be able to make sure your
content is fully optimized to the
fullest according to you know google's
algorithms and so you maybe you know
want to invest in that third-party tool
so these are good tools to use for
content optimization you know there's
also other key reddit but you know
there's keyboard planner uh in google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a google ads platform
and so if you don't have google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
google's keyword planner so having a
third party keyword tool will pay
dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
zarget okay so i'm gonna show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotshot.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with a
free account you can have hotjar measure
the heat map not only the heat map but
the click mapping the scrolling of a
particular page and so here you can see
we're looking at a particular page here
so hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
i switch over to move mode then i can
see on that particular page where people
are actually moving their mouse and then
i have my scroll analysis so i could see
you know how far down people actually
scroll on the page and so again with a
paid account you can measure up to 10
000 page views with the free version you
can measure up to 2000 pages and so 2
000 page views allows you to get some
insight as to what people are clicking
on or where they're moving or how
they're scrolling on a particular page
and so i definitely recommend hot jar
they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool i would recommend as well so one
final tool and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention it and that's google optimized
so google optimize is a google platform
that allows you to a b test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see i have
an account set up and optimize you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go into reporting here google
optimize does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at google
optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but you know to me google
optimize is free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests then that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so google optimize is a
tool that i would recommend so we live
in a world where everything is digitized
whether we're communicating reading
watching interacting everything is
digitized and one of the benefits of our
digitized world is opportunities and
those opportunities have arisen in the
world of digital marketing so
when we mean by digital marketing we
mean advertising to people via different
channels and so we're gonna hone in on
digital marketing and look at what those
opportunities are so let's talk a little
bit about digital marketing so digital
marketing really
involves selling a product or service
using several different online slash
digital marketing channels so some of
the most popular digital marketing
channels used by a lot of companies
today is seo which is search engine
optimization sem which is search engine
marketing that's paid search so if you
see a sponsored ad on google that would
be related to sem mostly you're probably
already familiar with email marketing
meaning you probably received an email
from a company trying to promote or sell
a product or service so those are some
of the most popular channels of course
there's other channels like video social
affiliate influencer marketing display
so there's a lot of different marketing
channels that fall under the umbrella of
digital marketing and so
those are some of the online marketing
channels used by companies to promote
their products and services and so in a
sense that's what digital marketing is
and so because digital marketing is
involves a lot of channels a lot of
companies need people to you know work
on those channels for that company
promoting that product or services so
let's take a look at some of those
particular roles involved with digital
marketing and the first one really is a
digital marketing manager so that's over
seeing all these different marketing
channels okay so somebody looking and
managing these different marketing
channels we just mentioned like seo
slash organic search or paid search or
social okay so digital marketing
managers oversee and implement these
different campaigns across different
channels with the strategy of either
brand awareness or
selling a particular product or
promoting the company services and so
with the digital marketing manager it's
a broad title in a sense but it comes
with a lot of responsibilities
so if we look at some of these
responsibilities it's really designing
and overseeing all the aspects of
digital marketing when we say all
aspects we don't mean just campaigns but
really what we mean is managing a
marketing database if you're
implementing campaigns and you're
collecting information as a result you
want to be able to store and manage that
information appropriately it also comes
down to
being able and being familiar and being
fluent in
different marketing channels like
jumping from email marketing to display
marketing when you manage multiple
campaigns and channels you have to have
a budget so you got to be able to
develop and maintain a budget so
being a digital marketing manager means
you know being able to
articulate and respond to channels that
are working and assigning budget
accordingly based on performance and not
only just assigning budget but making
sure the budget gets implemented
appropriately social is a big part of
digital marketing and so in itself
that's an 800 pound gorilla meaning it's
a lot of responsibility so plan and
manage social media platforms you know
for a lot of companies they're quick to
jump out there on the deep end when it
comes to social so digital marketing
manager really is someone who can reel
that in and say you know what look we
don't need to be on twitter or or
linkedin you know having that
responsibility taking the responsibility
for managing the social media platforms
accordingly what are the biggest jobs of
a digital marketing manager in my
opinion is maintaining reports and it's
not even maintaining reports i mean a
lot of tools like google analytics will
create the report for you we talk about
maintaining reports we really mean
looking at those reports looking at the
performance of these campaigns and
channels and reacting accordingly and
that leads to the next bullet point
really with the digital marketing
manager and that means coming up with
new growth strategies because if let's
just say a paid search campaign is
really performing okay how are we going
to grow that strategy how are we going
to grow that campaign vice versa if your
facebook ads aren't performing what can
we do to get them to grow and perform so
that's the job of a digital marketing
manager react according to the
performance of campaigns and continue to
grow and build out the campaigns and
channels and then with that comes you
know some side projects and some issues
that need to be resolved and so a good
digital marketing manager has their
pulse on everything related to that
particular digital marketing channel for
example a website okay if the website's
getting rebuilt or moving to a new
platform or being redesigned digital
marketing manager needs to be part of
that project and needs to be able to
help manage that project alongside the
channels and campaigns he or she is
responsible for so as you can see a lot
of responsibility
with a digital marketing manager so
with that responsibility comes
experience and so to jump into the deep
end on becoming a digital marketing
manager in my opinion you need to have
some experience maybe not across all
channels but at the very least some of
the most important channels we talked
about already seo
sem email
social uh email's been around a long
time seo is just so key it's the biggest
marketing channel out there your paid
search is very fast and dynamic involves
a lot of budget and management so you
need someone with experience and you
know someone with at least five years
experience in digital marketing or
advertising can fit the role of course
there's always going to be growth this
is digital marketing it's still young if
you compare digital marketing against
traditional platforms like tv or radio
or print we're only talking about 15 to
20 years of experience for digital
marketing out there as an advertising
platform so having five years out of 20
years of existence is not too bad now
with that comes a degree of some sort
with marketing okay so
you need to have at least a bachelor's a
master's degree really goes far because
usually those that contain a master's
degree usually as a have an mba or
masters of business administration and
to me that's a nice compliment to having
a nice set of experience in digital
marketing and so it's also a plus to
really have some knowledge about social
media okay some of the best practices uh
that go with social media
some of the analytics that go with
social media and not just social media
but in general too so what are some
digital marketing best practices that
you with your experience can apply
what's your knowledge of websites do you
have any programming experience do you
have any design experience do you have
any web analytics experience okay having
those skill sets meaning understanding
html or css or javascript or being able
to articulate how a website's performing
in google analytics definitely
complement the role of a digital
marketing manager in most cases is part
of the role of a digital marketing
manager and then one of the biggest
skills required i think every company
looks for this communication and
interpersonal skills so you have to be
able to communicate with your colleagues
with your stakeholders with your clients
with your contractors with anybody else
supporting your efforts or
the efforts you're supporting for
somebody else so communication is key
and today's world there's a lot of
communication tools out there i mean you
have traditional email you have text
messaging you have nice tools out there
like asana and slack to help you know
solidify the way communication is
streamlined and so you have to be able
to stay on top of communication because
you're going to be reporting up and
you're going to be reporting down to
you know those that are part of your
efforts and then a real big big bonus is
up to date with trends and technologies
and digital marketing so stay in the
know stay in the know attend conferences
attend webinars attending this webinar
definitely helps your positioning so
stay up to date and what i usually tell
you know other students
of mine is hey you know sign up for two
or three sources out there on the
internet it could be for example
google's webmaster blog or google
analytics video or youtube channel or
you subscribe to website magazine or
you know get an email subscription to
search engine land there's hundreds of
hundreds of thousands of resources out
there on the internet there's no excuse
not to stay up to date and then one
thing that's not listed here that i
would highly recommend is have a blog
having a blog offers up multiple
advantages one it promotes you as a
brand okay two whatever you're blogging
about and in this case it could be
something general like digital marketing
or could be a specific channel like seo
or could be analytically driven meaning
you know numbers and everything related
to digital marketing when it comes to
analytics whatever your niche is you
know write about it because it puts you
in a good position that one you're up to
date with the trends again you're
promoting your brand and two it shows
off your communication style so having a
blog whether you keep it updated once a
month twice a month four times a month
goes a long way versus not having a blog
at all because it shows you're
enthusiastic about the industry and the
job profession of digital marketing and
it really puts you in a good spot so
that's my recommendation there in
addition to all the skills required for
this position and you know salary
you know it depends it depends on
experience it depends on the company i
mean if you go with a non-profit versus
a poor for-profit company the pay might
be lower it depends on the company you
could go with a startup versus a more
traditional company and if the startup
they may pay more it really depends on
the company it really depends on the
industry the organization the experience
that you have the skill sets you bring
to the table all of that plays a role so
the salaries listed here are really just
averages
really it's averages because if you look
at 73 000 annually in the us okay if
you're you know get a nice digital
marketing job and say kansas 73 000 is a
lot of money
well it's all relevant because if you go
to california and san francisco 73 000
is not even the medium salary for
somebody who lives in san francisco so
it is contingent also on location so
what you need to do when it comes to
salary is take a look at your own
experience take a look at what you've
been paid previously if you have five
years experience and you're making fifty
thousand and you feel you've done a good
job and you've earned the skill sets and
the experience needed for the new
position you're applying for then
there's no reason why you can't ask for
more money than say the average okay so
really a lot of things are contingent on
salary but the one thing you can do to
control salary is make sure your skill
sets are in line with the job required
so let's move on to content strategist
and
you know content strategists it's just a
title that we're using for this webinar
um there's a lot of job titles out there
the key thing here with a content
strategist is somebody who's involving
themselves with content so they're
developing content okay so you can call
it a content writer a copy writer a
strategist a developer content developer
the king of content the queen of content
it doesn't really matter what the title
is when you see the word content you
know that your job is to develop content
that caters to the company's objectives
and so with a lot of digital marketing
channels out there today okay content
are in high demand very high demand so
some of the responsibilities that go
with a content strategist is you want to
be able to manage the editorial calendar
to ensure timely publication and what do
i mean by that well as a content
strategist you could be asked to write
social post supporting a social media
manager okay so you want to be able to
come up with a calendar of sorts to be
able to post at a specific point in time
that's going to ensure high engagement
so having some sense of time definitely
goes along with the job okay you want to
identify gaps and content and recommend
new topics so for example a blog if
you're responsible for generating
content for the company's blog you
probably want to take a look at the
categories and the topics that have
already been written about and you want
to be able to identify new areas of
content that's just an example but you
want to do that across all channels okay
you want to be able to create brand
style guides if a brand doesn't have a
style guide already that's a place where
you can really shine okay because a
brand needs to have a certain tone a
certain message a certain point of view
okay it needs to stand for something and
a good content strategist is one who can
help create it help
implement it help enforce it okay so
brand styling goes a long way with the
job okay being able to not only write
but proofread and edit pieces before
publishing them goes a long way too you
know some of the best content strategies
i've ever come across are ones that ask
me or colleague to proofread their own
content okay so
you know a good content strategist is
one that looks outward to make sure that
the copy or the content they're
producing is up to snuff it's aligned
with the brand it's articulate and is
centered and geared towards the intended
target audience so having somebody else
proofread to me says something about a
content strategist and vice versa being
able to proofread somebody else's work
to make sure yes what they're writing is
good solid grammatically written up the
brand intended for the right target
audience i mean so that's part of the
job being able to proofread and editing
okay another responsibility with a
content strategist is identifying
content topics based on keyword research
and this aligns with search okay so
with search engine optimization it's all
about keywords and you need to be able
to identify the content that goes along
with those keywords okay we talk about
this in depth on some of our other seo
webinars and i'll mention those in a
couple minutes but being able to
identify the content that aligns with
those keywords is really part of an seo
strategy and to me this next bullet
point really goes a long way you want to
be able to monitor web traffic and
engagement because if you're responsible
for the website if you're responsible
for producing content on a particular
website you want to see how that content
is performing so just because you're a
content strategist doesn't mean
necessarily you're not immune to looking
at data you are you're everybody has a
role when it comes to the website
everybody should take a look at data and
react accordingly to the data including
those who produce content and then you
want to be able to coordinate with
stakeholders in the organization because
the stakeholders are the one who ones
who are going to have some say and what
content so just like a digital marketing
manager to me another piece of
responsibility is for the content
strategist to be able to communicate
with the stakeholders let them know hey
this is the content that's going out
this is our editorial calendar hey let
me proofread some of your content hey
this is the brand style okay so the
content strategist really is somebody
who's center in terms of all content
that's developed for a particular
organization now some of the skills
required to me you know you can have a
nice marketing degree or journalism or
literature anything that's going to have
some background in writing some
experience as a content strategist or
manager or in a similar role so you
could be a blog ambassador for another
brand and fill the role of a content
strategist you can be an influencer and
be somebody who really influences
different companies and industries that
job would be able to fit a content
strategist because most influencers
write or produce content see i'm having
a basic understanding of html and web
publishing so you want to be able to
understand how the web works you know
you want to be able to stand what it
takes to create a web page because every
web page has content you need to have
experience with seo and you need to have
experience with keyword research tools
because to me a content strategist is
the one who drives this part of the seo
process to me the content strategist
looks at data when it comes to keyword
analysis is able to
aptly pick and choose keywords to align
with content and then write content not
just write content but optimize the
content for seo and then experience with
social media and not only just social
media but the different platforms out
there when i talk about understanding
social media for business and the
different platforms that can help a
business thrive in that channel you need
to understand you know the tended
audiences that go to that platform you
need to understand the formatting and
the opportunities for writing the
content on that platform you know
anybody can you know stroke a keyboard
and put words on a screen or break out a
pen and put words on paper but it really
takes someone with you know really fine
experience to really know who they're
writing for what platform they're
writing for
and the guidelines and the regulations
that go along with writing that content
so to me that separates out a good
content strategist from an average
content strategist and of course
excellent writing and editing skills go
a long way that comes with experience in
my opinion but what you could do if you
lack experience in editing is volunteer
for non-profit most non-profits have
blogs volunteer to write a blog post for
the non-profit or if you don't even want
to go that route like a digital
marketing manager have your own blog if
you have a passion for food or passion
for travel or passion for animals or
pets or dogs write about it that's
what's going to give you the experience
in writing editing and it shows hey look
you're enthusiastic about something and
it shows your brand and your tone so
like a digital marketing manager having
a blog goes a long way if you don't have
your own blog then be able to gain the
experience necessary in writing and
editing by doing it for others even if
it means pro bono volunteer so salary
just like a digital marketing manager
commencement on
a lot of factors experience location
organization
you know the department of the
organization the type of organization
the industry i mean like i said with the
digital marketing manager position hey
if you're at a startup you and you're
applying for content strategist role
chances are you're probably gonna ask
for more money than the average because
you're probably going to be writing
content not only for the website or the
blog not only for social but it could be
some offline opportunity as well meaning
press releases brochures tv ad spots
radio spots so you got to be open as a
content strategist especially when
you're working in a startup because
you're likely going to wear many hats
now if you're applying for a traditional
job at a company that's been around a
long time then your job may be really
focused and honed in on a specific you
know role so keep that in mind as well
so these salaries are average so a lot
of factors are involved so let's go into
seo so an seo specialist so it could be
an seo pundit an seo expert somebody
who's really familiar with the role and
the channel of seo so to me seo is a big
channel a lot of responsibility so
scs specialists are responsible for
analyzing reviewing implementing not
just changes to the website but things
that happen off the website because with
seo
seo is built into two branches or two
strategies off page and on-page okay so
being an seo specialist you got to be
able to hone in on what to do on your
own website for on-page seo but you got
to be able to be savvy enough to put
together an off-page strategy and not
only that you got to be technically
savvy because a lot of what goes into
seo involves some technical aspects like
4-4 page load or site maps or css
or
you know accelerated mobile pages mobile
usability
structured snippets featured snippets
all of these are factors that are
related to seo so an seo specialist is
somebody who really is able to juggle
both the website from a technical
standpoint on page optimization and off
page optimization it's a big role and so
therefore if we break down the
responsibilities again it's reviewing
and analyzing the site for improvement
and optimization in other words somebody
needs to be savvy enough if they're
called an seo specialist to be able to
conduct an audit for an seo strategy and
be able to identify areas of improvement
so preparing strategy reports so what
does that mean well that can mean a lot
of things so when we talk about strategy
and reports you need to be savvy enough
to create a keyword analysis okay you
need to be savvy enough to be able to
assign keywords you need to be savvy
enough to even know how to optimize a
page yes you may have a content
strategist do that work but as an seo
specialist you need to be able to know
how to do that as well okay you need to
be able to identify keywords okay in a
keyword analysis just like a content
strategist you need to be able to assign
keywords and you need to be able to
write effective seo content not only for
the blog or website and social media but
it could be across other different
channels as well so being part of the
content is part of being an seo
specialist because if you work at a
startup you may not have a quote-unquote
content strategist to support you so you
may have to do everything you may have
to you know not only audit the site you
may not only have to address some of the
website needs from a technical
standpoint but you may have to do the
keyword analysis the keyword assignments
and optimize the content for seo and
then take it to off page you may have to
write the content
for off page seo meaning social or it
could be on other platforms like
wikipedia medium reddit quora okay so
all of these platforms require content
that are part of an seo strategy so
being able to
you know prepare a strategy being able
to identify keywords via keyword
analysis being able to write content
that supports your seo strategy are all
part of the responsibilities of an seo
specialist and again part of that
strategy because it's on page and off
page is you need to be able to put
together an off-page seo strategy and
that's going to again involve content so
before you start writing content for
various platforms you need to be able to
put in a sound strategy what platforms
are we going to go after you know what
are the domain and page authority of
those platforms how much content do we
need to write how often the frequency
what type of content are we going to
write all of that's part of a link
building off-page seo strategy and to me
one of the biggest responsibilities of
an seo specialist is being able to not
only analyze keywords and seo techniques
used by your competitors but just being
able to analyze and measure seo overall
yes you need to be able to look at what
your competitors are doing but you need
to be able to for example
leverage an seo platform
look at that seo platform understand how
your overall seo efforts are performing
and continue to make adjustments so
that's an seo specialist wrapped up
and if we look at some of the skills you
know you need to have some seo
experience not having seo experience and
applying for an seo job is really
selling your stuff short because seo
involves some technical aspects some
creative aspects and some good sound
strategy along with a lot of analytics
so you need to be familiar
with analytics tools and other tools
that are going to measure the
performance of your seo strategy so
you need to be able to familiarize
yourself with some of the seo platforms
that are out there like moz or sem rush
because they produce analytic data as
well meaning ranking information or
domain and page authority you need to be
able to understand what those metrics
are and how to react to them you need to
be able to understand google analytics
from an organic search perspective you
know what are some of the kpis you're
aligning with organic search how are you
measuring organic search behavior from
an engagement standpoint or from a
conversion standpoint and because seo
has a technical aspect to it you need to
be able to understand you know the web
platform that you're on is it wordpress
okay how do plugins work do i have all
my plugins what theme am i using you
know what's the css of that theme so you
need to be able to understand all the
elements of your website that are going
to affect seo and so with that you need
to stay in the know you need to
understand all the different ranking
factors and how these different search
engines run in terms of their algorithms
you know the pundits say they're 200
plus different factors that affect
google's ranking algorithm so what are
those 200 ranking factors do you have a
certain knowledge set of how search
works okay do you know how the bots work
okay do you know the best practices for
site map okay so these are all the
things you need to know and all the
skills you need to obtain to be an seo
specialist and just like every position
we're going to cover and we've covered
already you need to stay up to date with
the latest trends and practices because
seo changes frequently google changes
their algorithms and they change their
algorithms without even letting you know
so you need to stay up to date with what
google's doing okay or some of the other
search engines and so there's a lot of
different resources available you need
to be savvy enough to pick and choose
the resources that are going to keep you
up to date you need to know
you know how search console works i mean
there's just a lot of different factors
involved with seo it's a very
well-rounded channel with a lot of
responsibility so you know if you don't
have the experience necessary well in my
opinion you can come in easily as a
content strategist you can come in as a
web developer and be an seo specialist
because you're going to have some
working knowledge of you know how a
website works or how social or off-page
seo works but an seo specialist is one
who puts it all together and so to me
you know salary again
these are just averages and they do vary
okay whether you're in india usa europe
other parts of asia south america you
know salary is going to be contingent on
location it's going to be contingent on
your experience and the one thing here
to prove your experience and to prove
your worth in terms of salary is to be
able to show what you've done in the
past in terms of progress for another
client or another website so you need to
be able to be able to show
you know those who you're looking to
work for here's what i've done in the
past here's the methodology here are the
metrics i used to measure
here are some of the results of that
effort okay so you need to be able to
show you know some case studies best
practices and historical performance and
to me if you could show that then you're
worth every bit of the salary that that
particular company would offer up so
let's move on to sem specialists so seo
specialist a lot of factors involved
there off page on pitch sem is search
but it's a whole different set of skills
versus seo a whole different skill set
and why because an sem specialist it
could be an sem manager or whatever
again you want to call it but the
channel here is sem search engine
marketing and and really somebody who's
part of sem is going to be able to
manage paid search campaigns across
multiple channels across multiple
networks okay so it may not even be just
a search network it could be the display
network okay so you need to know how
google and yahoo and bing and baidu and
linkedin and twitter all these paid
search platforms you need to know how
they work and be able to manage
campaigns effectively on those platforms
so some of the some of the
responsibilities now i will say this but
an s with sem it's very fast paced so
you need your responsibilities to keep
up with campaign performance and some of
the things you're going to do some of
the responsibilities you're going to
conduct while being by managing
campaigns are going to be testing a lot
of testing and a lot of analyzing data
okay so you need to be able to react to
the data you see okay so you need to
identify trends to achieve maximum
return on investment so in my opinion a
good sem specialist is one who
identifies their kpis beforehand and
then identifies the strategy beforehand
and then being able to execute that
strategy and then after executing that
strategy being able to optimize the
campaign so you're able to achieve
maximum performance and maximum results
that's really the job of an sem
specialist so you need to be able to
execute according to strategy you need
to be able to track and report on the
performance and not just track and
report but you need to be able to react
because with pay-per-click or cost per
click or sponsored search or search
engine marketing whatever you want to
call it it's going to be fast-paced
meaning you're going to get data and
you're going to get data very quickly
and so you have to be good at looking at
numbers and reacting to those numbers
and another
major responsibility is being able to
manage a budget if a client gives you
money you need to be able to manage that
budget accordingly first things first
you need to be able to plot a strategy
that's going to spend that budget wisely
and you need to be able to monitor and
maintain that budget so you don't
overspend the budget and not only just
overspend the budget but underspend the
budget so if a client hands you a
thousand dollars don't spend 500 of it
don't spend 1500 of it spend a thousand
look at the results along the way and
come back to the client tell them hey
here's the maximum results for that
thousand dollars and here's what i
recommend moving forward based on the
work and the optimization we've done
that's part of being an sem specialist
is being able to manage and maintain the
budget and maximize your efforts for
those paid search campaigns while you're
spending that budget and some of the
other responsibilities with an sem
specialist is not just managing numbers
and data it's being able to write ad
copy and not only write a copy but know
the different guidelines and formats of
these different paid campaigns and
platforms because the guidelines for
google are going to be different from
the guidelines on facebook and so you
need to be able to also react to that ad
copy according to the platform and not
only the ad copy but the landing pages
as well you need to be able and be savvy
and technically savvy enough to be able
to set up unique landing pages for your
pay-per-click campaigns okay that's part
of an sem specialist leading the way on
creating landing pages and not just
creating landing pages but also doing a
b testing on those landing pages a good
sdm specialist with experience is going
to be able to
raise their hand and say look this
landing page is not performing let's put
an a b test in place so that we can
improve performance of our paid search
campaign so
one of the ultimate jobs of an scm
specialist is always always looking at
keywords being able to identify keywords
that are performing you know being savvy
enough to pause the keywords that are
not performing being able to optimize
keywords to gain better performance and
to expand the keyword list whether that
be in a different campaign or ad group
or you know ad set so identifying and
managing keywords is probably the number
one job of an scm specialist because
keywords are what drive a lot of paid
search especially on google yahoo and
bing so a lot of responsibility within
sem specialists you're giving the
responsibility of running a campaign
against a budget and you have to move at
a fast pace so it's not an easy role
it's not for the fainted heart you need
to be able to react to data at a very
fast pace and so what are some of the
skills required for job like this well
you need to have experience with search
engine marketing in general but it would
help to have experience across multiple
platforms i would even go as far as not
just saying yahoo and bing and google
but facebook linkedin
adroll and not only just google search
but you need to be able to show that you
can manage paid search campaigns across
google's display network meaning display
banners and even video campaigns on
youtube or remarketing campaigns or
shopping ad campaigns so you need to
have a well-rounded
view and well-rounded experience on how
search works and all the different types
of campaigns you can run on a search
platform you need to be well versed in
metrics paid search is about reacting to
data and performing the campaign at the
maximum so if you're managing a campaign
for an e-commerce website what are your
kpis what's your cost per acquisition
you know if i'm selling a t-shirt for
twenty dollars do i want my cost per
acquisition to be twenty five dollars no
so you need to be able to understand the
different metrics and different kpis
align with a specific strategy or
website or business and you need to
manage against those metrics whether
that be cost per acquisition or
conversion rate or raw conversions you
need to be staying up to date with the
latest sem trends because paid search
especially on google they come out with
a lot of features and updates all the
time and you need to be able to know
what those updates are so you could take
advantage of them do you know that you
know google offers up responsive ads
okay do you know that they have
different ad extensions for say mobile
or location okay you need to stay up to
date with all the features on every
platform so you can maximize those
features for your clients again you need
to have strong analytical skills you
know if you're not good with numbers
then being an scm specialist is probably
not for you being comfortable with
numbers and being able to react to those
numbers that's a sign of a good strong
analytical skill set now sem involves a
lot of testing because a b testing and
pay-per-click go together because
pay-per-click's a controlled environment
so doing a b testing and being able to
identify a b testing not just for
landing pages but for ad copy so you
need to be able to
be familiar with how a b testing works
and being comfortable you know
identifying areas that need a b testing
coming up with variations coming up with
those kpis and then having a
well-rounded knowledge of how a website
works never hurts because you may be
tasked with setting up the a b test for
landing page so to me you know being an
scm specialist it's a cool cool job i
particularly like pay per click it's
very fast paced you get to react you get
to do a lot of different things here um
across different platforms and to see
the fruits of your labor pay off for the
client meaning good campaign performance
is well worth the reward of being an scm
specialist and again
you know we're looking at 65 000 in the
us and that's contingent on experience
and to me
i would probably go as far as saying you
know you need to have at least five
years experience as an sem specialist
and you need to be able to show a
well-rounded view of what you've managed
in the past so whether that be paid
search campaigns on google search
display video shopping remarketing you
know social paid ads on different
platforms like linkedin twitter facebook
you know you could even do paid search
on other platforms or websites as well
and even understanding you know how
adsense works you know the other way
around how a publisher gets money
because that's part of the display
network so looking at if not from an
advertiser point of view but from a
publisher standpoint so showing a
well-rounded knowledge of how paid
search works really goes a long way into
how much you actually make as an sm
specialist let's move over to social
media marketer so social media social
media marketers are in high demand
because a lot of companies are on social
media so social media marketers achieve
customer engagement intimacy they want
to drive website traffic they want to
convert that traffic to revenue okay so
they want to take advantage of all the
features available on that particular
social media platform and so some of the
responsibilities involved with being a
social media marketer involves you know
building and executing a strategy on
that particular social media strat
platform so you want to be able to look
at what your competitors are doing you
want to put in a good strategy and when
i say a good strategy that means
identifying what platforms identifying
the messaging okay is it going to be
brand or seo based or sales based okay
being able to build an audience on that
platform knowing who your target
audience is okay that's first and
foremost from a social media perspective
a good social media marketer needs to
know what they're getting themselves
involved with before they execute okay
and then once you are able to plan and
strategize
then comes the work you need to be able
to generate edit publish and share
content and the whole point here is it's
based on strategy so is it brand
awareness is it community building at
the end of the day you're going to want
to see some type of engagement or you're
going to want to be able to see
something in return for the content
you're posting so are you in for likes
or are you in for shares or are you in
for website traffic or are you in for
conversions okay so you need to be able
to manage that based on the content you
publish and so to me when you're talking
about content and you're talking about
social media you need to be able to lean
on a good social media platform there
are plenty out there like buffer or
or sprout social or hootsuite or later
there are plenty of social media
platforms out there and you need to
familiarize yourself and be able to
leverage that social media platform to
manage your content manage the data
you're seeing from the social media
platforms and then basically the whole
idea behind social is it's based on a
strategy so you need to be able to
improve that strategy by analyzing those
metrics insights and understand some of
the best practices in order to improve
so
it's a very broad sense of
responsibilities because it does depend
on the platform it does depend on the
business it does depend on your strategy
you could just be responsible for
twitter okay so twitter has you know
very limited number of characters
involved content but just because
there's not a lot of content doesn't
mean the strategy isn't as intense as it
would be on facebook or linkedin so you
need to be able to adjust and adapt to
the platform you're working on and so to
me some of the skills required you know
it helps to have an mba but i think it
definitely does help to have
as a social media marketer you know two
years is probably good enough experience
but in my opinion the more experience
you have and the more experience you
have across
multitude of platforms definitely says
something about your skill set so it
needs to cross over as well it needs to
cross over that skill set needs to cross
over into different marketing channels
for example paid search why because you
could be asked to write content for paid
ads on facebook it needs to be able to
cross over in seo why because you could
be asked to write content for off-page
seo on a particular social media
platform it needs to be able to cross
over and say email because you could be
contributing to that email newsletter
that goes out that's pulling snippets of
content from your social work so you
need to familiarize yourself with how
different marketing channels work
because they overlap with social media
and then just like a content strategist
just like seo sem a digital marketing
manager you need to be able and be
comfortable going into google analytics
or your analytics platform you need to
be able to identify social as a channel
and be able to measure how that
particular channel is working and not
only how it's working in terms of your
kpis which could be engagement or
conversion based but you need to be
savvy enough to react to the data let's
just say you're not driving enough
traffic from facebook and facebook is
your primary social media platform what
are you going to do how are you going to
adjust that strategy
to drive more traffic so that's a good
savvy social media marketer somebody
who's able to go into an analytics
platform and react to the data they're
seeing based on the strategy that
they're trying to implement and then you
know having well-rounded experience with
all the different social networking and
social analytics tools definitely shows
your experience if you have one
experience a little experience with just
one platform like sprout social then get
experience jump into hootsuite or buffer
or some of these other platforms and
know the differences between them
because
basically one social media platform may
not work for one company you may have to
lean on one or two based on the features
that they offer and you need to be savvy
enough to identify that so that you can
assist the organization you're working
for so that to me shows a lot of
maturity and experience knowing where to
go to maximize your efforts so social
media marketers they're in abundance but
they're in need okay so
you can really niche yourself a good
career whether that be at a startup or
whether it be in a traditional company
whether it be a non-profit or for-profit
whether that be in tech or real estate
or law or medical or insurance it
doesn't matter social media marketers
are in need but a good social media
marketer are those that take into
account the skills we talked about okay
let's turn our attention to email
marketing
so let's take a look at email marketing
here so email marketing has been around
a long time so email marketing
specialists if you will are those that
promote the organization organizations
product or services via email so the aim
is to really get those emails to work so
email marketing has been around
most people today have email addresses
are familiar with email marketing
because most organizations use email
marketing as a digital marketing channel
and so a good email marketing specialist
is responsible for the design and the
implementation of an email marketing
campaign and so to me they need to be
able to also identify the platform that
they're going to be working with so if
you're going to implement an email
marketing campaign you need to be able
to identify the platform that you're
going to work in and there are plenty of
email marketing platforms and there are
plenty of marketing automation tools
that offer up email as a feature so you
need to be able to identify
not only a marketing automation platform
that works with your email marketing
strategy but a good email marketing
platform you know there's vertical
response there's mailchimp there's you
know a lot of different marketing pla
email marketing platforms out there so
try and test a few of them
and understand how they work just like
social media there's an abundance of
email marketing platforms so you need to
be able to identify one that's going to
align with the strategy and give you all
the features and benefits available and
you need to be able to identify your
target audience because you're not going
to send one email to your entire
audience list you're going to need to be
able to dissect that entire audience
list into different segments and that's
what a good email marketing specialist
does identify different segments of
audience you need to be just like a
content strategist able to proofread
copy in some cases you may be writing
that copy for the email if you work at a
startup and you don't have a content
strategist maybe you are a content
strategist who is also assigned as an
email marketing specialist either way
you need to be able to
look at the copy that's in that email
and ask yourself you know is this copy
intended for target audience does it fit
our brand guidelines does it fit our
brand messaging do the call to actions
fit what we're trying to achieve you
know all that's part of an email
marketing specialist an email marketing
specialist needs a good set of eyes and
you need to understand the technical
aspects of email because no longer are
we sending email to somebody on a
computer on a desktop who's downloading
that email onto say some software
program like outlook not today today
most people are looking at email on the
fly on the go via mobile so we need to
make sure that emails you know fit our
audience across multiple devices so you
need to be able to ensure that
you know your emails are mobile friendly
because most people are looking at
emails on their mobile phones and timing
is everything with email
metrics just like any other channel is
important with email so you need to know
when you're going to be able to send
that email what time of day you're going
to be able to send that email and you
need to understand the campaign
performance why
so that you can respond and optimize the
email marketing efforts moving forward
and then another responsibility not
really listed here but it does go with
the job and that's a b testing so just
like an sem specialist you need to be
able to understand how a b testing works
why because you may not just be
optimizing
landing pages for an a b test you may be
looking at an a b test for subject lines
in fact a good email marketing
specialist never sends out an email
without a b testing the subject line and
so you need to be familiar with how a b
testing works because that goes along
with improving campaign performance and
knowing
industry policies and best practices
especially with email goes a long way
because there are a lot of regulations
involved around you know email and it
does come down to also the industry what
you could say and what you can't say by
industry does factor in so staying up to
date with industry policies and best
practices definitely is part of the
responsibility of an email marketing
specialist now skills required
should have experience with email
marketing and to me i would take this a
step further you know having
well-rounded experience working for a
startup working for a larger company and
working for a company that has different
target audiences meaning segmented
audiences you can show that hey i know
how to send out an email to a large
number of people and they could be
subsets of a bigger audience and you
need to be able to show you know the
different styles and the different
platforms uh for email marketing that
you've worked with and a lot of email
requires html or knowledge of html so
you're gonna have to know html because
you may have to edit html you need to
know how utm tracking works okay urchin
tracking modules so if you don't know
what utm tracking is and you want to be
an email marketing specialist you need
to know what that is and get some
hands-on experience using utm tracking
because you need to track emails and if
you're using google analytics azure
analytics platform then you definitely
will need utm tracking because you need
to be able to be comfortable to go into
google analytics and look at your email
campaign performance does it align with
your kpis and you need to be able to
have some project management skills
because a lot goes into email marketing
you know it's the design of it it's the
timing of it it's the copy it's the a b
testing it's the analytical part if
you're working for a big company that
has 35 different target audiences you
could be sending out multiple emails on
a daily basis for different audiences
and so you need to be able to project
manage each of these email campaigns and
so those are the skills required for an
email marketing specialist and again
salary contingent upon experience the
more experience you have as an email
marketer the more you're gonna make and
experience to me is based on you know
how many email marketing platforms you
work with how many companies have you
done email marketing for how
well-rounded have your emails been how
many target audiences how big have those
target audiences been do you understand
the concept of analytics and the concept
of a b testing so if you do and you
checked off all those boxes then you can
command more than what the average is
for an email marketing specialist so
let's take a look at a digital marketing
resume so my recommendation and this is
just my opinion
would be to build your resume off a
platform like linkedin so if you're not
on linkedin then i would definitely
recommend you get on linkedin and if
you're going to be a social media
marketer then you definitely should be
on linkedin if you're going to be a
content strategy even digital marketing
manager you need to be on linkedin
linkedin is a business to business
platform so it allows you to put your
best foot forward in front of a lot of
people so not only those you connect
with but there's a lot of recruiters who
work on linkedin and these recruiters
are looking for people with experience
who fit the job they're trying to fill
and so to me
we look at a good resume you know
especially on linkedin linkedin allows
you to have a platform to put in all
your experience and so
you know depending on what you're trying
to go for i would niche towards that so
if you're going to be a digital
marketing manager then you could see in
this example two years experience with
content seo marketing automation email
sem and market research those are part
of the skill sets required for digital
marketing manager so you want to put in
a summary a good summary to include how
much experience you have and anything
that supports your claim to be a digital
marketing manager or an email marketing
manager or social media marketing
manager that's part of the summary and
then you want to put your experience in
there and to me putting your experience
in there is key i would include all your
experience everything you've ever done
geared towards the job you're going for
and to me
one thing about experience is when you
write out your experience put in what
your responsibilities were and then i
think what's key here in this example
you could see
this person had associate digital
marketing manager experience for one
year and what they did was they actually
showed the improvements they made as a
digital marketing manager so you can see
increased organic pages 30
with the reduction of bounce rates on
websites through site content management
and sem analysis so they actually put
some quantitative data in there to show
that hey this is what i've done and this
is what i've done to improve this
particular company's
website and so to me it's action
oriented it shows some quantitative
analysis it shows you've actually done
work that made improvement and it also
shows that you have command of analytics
because every job under the digital
marketing realm involves quantitative
and analytical data and so putting
analytical data in your resume
shows that you know what you're talking
about so here you can see on the next
example hey as a marketing intern for
nike you know one good year here's all
the tools i've worked with so
to me that's also a plus you want to
show again a lot of these positions
require knowledge of some of the most
common platforms okay whether that an
analytical platform an email marketing
platform an seo platform or social media
platform if you worked in that platform
put it down it shows that you're
well-rounded and so that's a good
suggestion to show hey you have
experience working with these platforms
and hey you have command of analytics
obviously putting your education down
there you know to me i'm not a recruiter
i don't think cpa is such a big deal to
me experience is more of a big deal and
then you definitely to support that
experience to show that you're in the
know the show that you stay up to date
that show
that you're up to date with the latest
trends and best practices i would
definitely put your certifications and
so if you're trying to be an sem
specialist or strategist then make sure
you have google ads certifications and
not just google ads but all facets of
google ads and what google ads has to
offer get your certification in mobile
get your certification and video get it
in shopping get it in display put their
certifications down there because it
shows you're well-rounded and regardless
of what position you're going for
whether it be content or email go for
the google analytics certification all
these certifications i mentioned by
google are free bing has certifications
facebook has certifications get those
certifications and put them down there
because again it shows that you're in
command of your career it shows that
you're up to date with the latest and
greatest it shows that you know what
you're talking about because you've
taken the initiative to get a
certification so to me these are all the
key ingredients to a good resume you
know niche it to what you're trying to
do write a good summary that supports
your effort you put your experience down
there but when you put your experience
support it with quantitative
measurements and metrics put down all
the experience you have with platforms
you know put some other
elements in there that are intangibles
like communication you know show that
you know how to communicate hey we use
slack to communicate to a team of 100
across
five different countries as an example
because it shows that you have a grasp
of what it takes to communicate with a
team at large of course put your
education but more importantly get those
certifications put them down there
because it shows you know what you're
doing you're walking the walk not just
talking the talk so if you're interested
in a career in digital marketing and you
don't have the necessary experience and
say google analytics then take a look at
our google analytics tutorial for
beginners you know looking over the
webinar give you some more insight into
google analytics and propel you into
maybe taking the certification likewise
we have one for email marketing if
you're interested in being an email
marketer you know take a look at our
webinar and email marketing and then seo
if you don't have the necessary
experience and you're not sure of
everything involved in seo then take a
look at seo tutorial for beginners so we
have a lot more webinars available at
simply learn so if you're lacking in one
area the other you know go to our
channel on youtube to fill in the gaps
of what you need to enhance your career
search engine optimization we're going
to go through a series of questions and
i'm going to answer those questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my seo courses on youtube for seo we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put i mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know files just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to
site b we could put a nofollow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the crawlers hey
don't follow this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow text so just a
reminder link jews is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a no follow
well it depends it really depends a lot
of social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engine to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that nofollow there they're
not going to follow that link and vice
versa if there's a link on another site
pointing to yours and there's a no
follow there you're not going to get
credit the search engines aren't going
to pick up that link okay so question
two what is 301 redirect and how is it
different from a 302 redirect so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we
don't have a page anymore we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary
so we want the search engines to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in google search index
and we get it sometimes pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just gonna build our credibility
it's gonna increase increase our domain
authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get more of a lion's
share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found and getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so the
whole idea for seo is remember you have
an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter or facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtag and
then this goes about saying you did all
the work created a really great video
it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are going to see that
engagement they're going to see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google for
example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so with that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look i'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my website
is for mobile devices in google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bop and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so
nap is name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then
also just as important opt for reviews
and ratings okay so the more reviews the
hat you have the better off you are okay
so i always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors and
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the key word the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local seo okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just seo 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and the third option is opt for
preferred domain in google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three i would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell search engines hey this
is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you could
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy server you may be
sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to can have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for seo okay optimize your code
what do you mean by
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the redundant code if you have
css you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the javascript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a
cache version of that page and then off
for the content delivery network as well
so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google
pagespeed and you're gonna get this tool
pagespeed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is gonna analyze the
url for both mobile and desktop and so
here we could see google gives a score
so we could see the score from mobile
and we could see the score for desktop
just by clicking on desktop and so here
i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i can see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
anywhere you can just always google it
as well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of
how quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
load time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be
in the united states and have worse
network service than you do say
in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of seo
okay so if somebody asked me this
question in an interview what am i going
to focus on while developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture and navigation we want to
have a simple url structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and need okay if you
have five products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
want to make it clean and neat and easy
for somebody to find the the rule of
thumb is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a
sitemap now what is that sitemap a
sitemap is simply just a formatted file
with to that includes all your urls and
assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want google or
these these bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com
sitemap.xml
okay you want to take that sitemap and
make sure you input that sitemap
location in google search console that
way google search console has a one-way
ticket to grab the elements in the
sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a website is
having a robot's text file and all a
robot's text file is it's like a lock i
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's going to be
able to get in that door so that's all a
robot's text file is you're telling
google and these other bots that are
coming across your site what's locked
and what's not logged meaning what they
have access to what they don't have
access to so you want to be able to make
sure you have a robot's text file if
you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason site
map you want google to get these pages
and assets quickly okay you want to make
sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where are
they located along with the videos and
images okay and then the robot's text
just instructs the search engine
crawlers to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way okay so those are
our questions for seo again if you have
any additional questions or if there are
other questions maybe you've been asked
in an seo interview then go ahead and
add them to the comments section below
we'd love to hear from you now we're
going to turn our attention to search
engine marketing so let's turn our full
attention to search engine marketing uh
so we're moving away from seo and over
to pay per click and so you really have
to know your stuff here you really do uh
so a lot of the questions we're gonna
ask gonna be centered around google ads
formerly known as google ads words and
so if you're familiar with google ads
the platform then you should have no
problems whatsoever answering these
questions but that's why we're here and
that's why you're watching so
there's anything you want to add to any
of these questions as a reminder feel
free to comment under the video and so
right out of the gate question 11 what
is ad scheduling so ad scheduling is a
feature in google ads and really all it
does is allow you the advertiser to set
up certain hours or days you want your
ads to shout it's as simple as that so
if you have a customer that you're
running
ads for on google search and
let's just say they have a restaurant
and they're closed during certain hours
of the week then you can go into the ad
scheduler and schedule your ads to not
show when they're closed as an example
okay because if somebody calls and
they're not there to answer the phone
then it's not going to be good for the
restaurant or you the advertiser and so
that's why they have the ad scheduling
so it ensures your ads are not running
when they're performing poorly let's
just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you could serve your customers
when you do have limited client service
hours so let's just say you have a
customer service team that's going to
answer phones for a couple hours a day
well again you can schedule your ads to
show during those couple of hours a day
and then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you can satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of ad scheduling schedule
it according to the business hours
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're gonna have
poor performance okay so next question
what are the different ad formats
available on google ads it's a trick
question because it really does come
down to what network you're advertising
on so google has two networks the search
network and the display network okay so
on the search network there's only one
ad format and that's text okay so google
recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ad extensions and
so you can see here underneath the ad
you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on
ear headphones those are all site links
to specific pages on the site so
text ads are available only on the
search network but they're also
available on the display network as well
then you have responsive display ads now
responsive responsive display ads are
only on google's display network okay so
here you could see
some samples of responsive display ads
and these ads adjust their size and
format depending on the space available
so again you could have text ads or you
can have display ads now display ads
again come in different sizes so you can
create ads for a variety of different
sizes for example 250 by 250 or 468 by
60. so those are some of the different
ad types there's there's an a plethora
of different ad sizes you can choose
however your ads not going to show on a
website if they don't have that
particular size available so it's always
best practice to create different ads
but create ads in different sizes as
well okay and then have a backup text ad
as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
google will automatically
show the ad that's best performing based
on a series of headlines descriptions
and images that use you provide google
and so the responsive part is hey if
this combination of headline description
and image work best meaning it has the
best click-through rate then google's
going to serve up that ad so that's why
they call it responsive so obviously
gonna have just an image ad that's not
responsive again across different ad
sizes you know they could be again 250
by 250 300 by 300 468 by six there's a
number of different sizes google can
provide you that information but the one
thing to note here is that when you do
create an image ad it could be
jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
png for example or it could be a static
or it could be interactive so
definitely take advantage of the
different opportunities uh meaning a
static ad versus an interactive ad you
may want to have two variations of that
so you could see which one works best
okay there's also app promotion ads so
these ads are used to drive app download
so you're going to have to set up a
campaign accordingly okay but here you
can see this is what it looks like with
the call to action so it allows you to
go ahead and click and install that app
so that's an app promotion again if you
have an app and you want to promote it
you can use this type of ad format to
align with a campaign that's driving
traffic to download your app okay and of
course you have video ads well google
owns youtube and so if you have videos
you have the opportunity to advertise on
youtube okay so these ads can be
standalone or inserted into other
streaming video content and so to me
video ads work well with specific
strategies and what's one strategy you
would use a video ad for brand awareness
or education explainer videos and so
youtube allows you the advertiser the
opportunity to get your ad your service
your product in front of a lot of
eyeballs so that's the beauty of video
ads they attract a lot of eyeballs and
definitely help with the strategy of say
brand awareness another ad format going
back to the search network is shopping
ads so if you sell shoes then you may
want to think about having a campaign
for shopping so shopping ads work with
google merchant so google merchant is
another google product and basically
google merchant allows you to manage
your inventory so if you have a hundred
different types of shoes that you're
selling you can upload your inventory to
google merchant connects and talks to
google ads so basically what you're
doing you're setting up your your
campaign and google ads and connecting
your inventory from google merchant to
google ads and so the great thing about
the shopping campaign is it puts your
product front and center it puts the
price it puts any promotion that you
have and it puts the brand all front and
center so when somebody does type in
let's just say lime green sneakers or
women's sneakers and this particular
shoe shows up here the third one from
the left then somebody's going to see
it's from the united colors of benaton
it's a woman's shoe it's on amazon and
it costs 45
so the great thing about shopping ads is
if somebody's interested they're gonna
click okay if somebody's not interested
say well you know it's a little bit more
expensive i can get something similar
another shoe on amazon for less okay
they're probably gonna click on that
particular app so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so
you can showcase your shopping ads so
these ads have an image and a
description that expand when clicked so
you can provide more information more
product and store information as well
you also have call only ads okay so call
only ads are enabled to users to connect
with your business directly using the
phone number provided okay so it allows
somebody on a mobile phone who in this
example is searching for drywall repair
well if you're in the business of
drywall repair you can have your ad show
up on mobile with the phone number and
somebody can easily click on that phone
number and just call you directly now
the way
call only ads work is you're still
getting charged for the click okay so
anytime somebody clicks and calls you're
going to get charged and you're going to
get charged just as you would if
somebody clicked on your ad so it works
the same way so it's a cost per click
again this is on search so search is
cost per click and the beauty about call
only is again you can track the calls
riding google ads so you can have google
ads track how many people click on the
number and you can even count those
calls as conversions if they meet a
certain criteria for example the
criteria is somebody
talks to you for a minimum of 60 seconds
or one minute then google will count
that as a conversion so you can monitor
calls right in google ads and it's a
cost per click model so you can actually
see what the average cost per click is
so moving on question 13. okay what is
rlsa and how does it work well
rlsa stands for remarketing list for
search ads so if you're familiar with
remarketing on display it's similar they
just call it rlsa okay so it enables you
the advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you could tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
google and search partner sites okay so
they're two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site the key here is you're the
one that's picking the customer you're
the one that's enabling the list if
you're trying to target people who went
to your site and didn't convert well you
could certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site into convert or you could set
up a whole new campaign for rllsa
and have a different set of keywords
with a different ad because you know who
you're talking to you're talking to
somebody who's already been to your site
they know your brand they just didn't
purchase and so this all happens on the
search network and that's the beauty of
remarketing is one you know who your
audience is because you're the one
establishing that audience and two
you're the one creating the ad so you
can talk directly to that audience when
they see your ad again in this case on
search so that's rlsa remarketing list
for search ads i recommend pretty much
any industry any client any customer run
remarketing list for search advertising
and remarketing for display so those are
two key campaigns you should always
recommend running to a client because
one again you're defining the audience
two
you're the one that's talking directly
to the ones because you know who the
audience is and three if they see the ad
and they click on it again because it's
cost per click then the chances of
converting are going to be higher
because they've already been your
website they know who you are and so if
they click on your ad again then they
must be interested so those are all the
benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn google's
display network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have affinity audiences so
basically affinity audiences are
basically
what are people's interests and habits
what do they have an affinity for are
there food sites travel sites shopping
sites fashion okay so that's what
affinity really relates to okay then you
have in market custom intent life events
these are what they're researching or
planning for so again it could be travel
it can be finance etc okay you have
remarketing we just went over that with
remarketing list for search advertising
our lsa and so with the remarketing it's
an audience that has interacted with
your website so they either came from
mobile or came from mobile and didn't
convert or female came from mobile and
didn't convert so you're the one
defining the audience there you also
have a similar audience so this is what
google creates on your behalf so these
are users with a similar interest to
your site visitors so google is
monitoring the type of traffic that's
coming to your site and based on that
traffic they're going to create a
similar audience and then you have a
custom match so what you know about your
customers activities basically so these
are all the different audience types and
you can see the different types of ads
available okay so notice the far right
column video ads so video ads are
available to every one of these audience
types why because youtube so google
knows what people's interests and habits
are based on the videos they watch they
know what they're looking for okay they
you know that they've been to your
website because they're cooking so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in google ads okay so this is a good
question
very important if you're gonna manage a
google ads account and a campaign you
have to be aware of the different match
types you can't just go broad match
that's a sign of somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing is by bidding on
a one keyword phrase that's a short tail
keyword if you think back to seo we have
our long tail and our short tail
keywords the worst thing you could do is
bid on a keyword short tail keyword
that's broad match because what is broad
match basically broad match or keywords
that appear when a user searches any
word in the phrase now you could define
specifically
what you want your ads to appear for in
terms of keywords and when i say
specifically you can use a phrase match
so phrase match are ads that appear only
when a user searches for that exact
keyword phrase in the precise order but
with some additional words in the
beginning or at the end of the query
okay so usually these are sentences so
you could be you know bidding on red
adidas running shoes and somebody could
type in looking for red adidas running
shoes in portland oregon as an example
okay so as long as red adidas running
shoes are in order in that keyword
phrase then your ads going to appear
because it's a phrase match and then you
can get really specific by doing an
exact match so exact match are keywords
that are triggered only when that
keyword and exactly that keyword phrase
is queried so if you do an exact match
for
red adidas running shoes and somebody
types in only red adidas running shoes
then that's an exact match and your ads
going to appear so let's take a look at
these again so you got broad match okay
we got a term cheap smartphone so if
somebody types in smartphone cheap phone
smart mobile phone cheap any one of
those combinations your ads going to
appear now there's one thing you can do
for broad match and it's called broad
match modifier so you could put a plus
sign in front of the keyword for example
let's just say you really want to
emphasize the word cheap okay you're
selling really inexpensive smartphones
okay not just any smartphone but an
inexpensive smartphone so you can put a
plus sign in front of cheap and so
somebody puts in you know just
smartphone or smart mobile your ads not
going to show up because the word the
keyword query has to contain sheep so
anytime you put a plus in front of the
keyword query you're bidding on then
that means that keyword has to be part
of the keyword phrase so that's a a
broad match modifier if you will and
that prevents you from getting unwanted
impressions so we have phrase match
again blue smartphone so somebody could
type in smartphone in blue color
cheap blue smartphone notice though the
second one where it says smartphone and
blue color your ads not necessarily
gonna show up because guess what blue
smartphone is the keyword query and
you're at uh your the query here is not
in that order so remember in order for
you to show up for phrase match the
keyword has to be in that order so i'm
looking for a blue smartphone that is
less than 100
okay that could be somebody's query blue
smartphone was in that query in that
order so if somebody says looking for a
smartphone that happens to be blue less
than a hundred dollars then your ad is
not going to show up so remember it has
to be in that ex precise order one thing
i want to go back to on the phrase match
notice that there's quotes around the
keyword anytime you see quotes around
the keyword that signifies it's a phrase
match because if we look at exact match
notice there are brackets around the
keyword red shoe that signifies is an
exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then you're signifi
signaling to google that this is an
exact match and i only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and footwear
that's red is not going to work because
this is an exact match so you're saying
i only want to show up for the keyword
red shoe and google recognizes plurals
and singulars together so somebody did
type in red shoes then your ad is going
to show up okay so moving on what are
some of the reasons as to why your ads
could have been rejected it happens to
the best of us and if you're writing ads
and they get rejected it could be for a
number of reasons so at the end of the
day you're violating google's
advertising policies so
some of the policies that could have
been violated are and just some of the
many we're just listing some here
prohibited content prohibited practices
restricted content or editorial
technical so when you look at prohibited
content i will say this you're not going
to be able to sell drugs even if you're
selling pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so you're gonna definitely get
flagged for that okay so there are a lot
of different ways in which your ads can
be disapproved okay but if you do see
restricted content then that means you
can advertise but with limitations and
usually those limitations are restricted
to say only google search and not google
search partners or to a specific
geography so usually the key here is if
somebody asks this question okay there
are a lot of different reasons google is
usually going to provide the specific or
the reason why it got disapproved and
they're usually going to include a link
that you can refer to okay so at least
google does that much they're not going
to leave you in the dark and tell your
ads just been disapproved they're going
to tell you why and include a link that
you can go to figure out how you can
best resolve the disapproved ad so what
are the different kinds of bidding
available in google ads so we already
covered part of this earlier on so
remember google search network is only
cost per click cpc when we talk about
google's display network you have three
options cost per click cost per view and
cost per impression and cpm is cost per
1000 impressions so you're paying per
1000 impressions impression is when
somebody actually sees your ad cost per
view
is actually somebody looking at your ad
for at least 30 seconds or the entirety
of the ad so if the ad video ad only
runs 15 seconds and somebody watched the
entirety then you're going to pay per
cost per view so if your video is two
minutes long and somebody watched 30
seconds you're gonna pay cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost per view again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1000
impressions so this is the amount you
pay each time your ad is displayed in
the search network and you pay for
impressions that are in generated for
your ad and you're paying for every 1000
impressions so the m is actually the
normal
roman numeral for 1000 so that's where
the m part comes in so you're paying for
1 000 impressions so every 1 000
eyeballs you're going to pay a price and
so cost per impression is good for brand
awareness if you're trying to generate a
lot of eyeballs onto your brand then
you'd want to go with a cpm model okay
so question 18 what are some automatic
bidding strategies so let's define
automatic bidding strategy automatic
bidding allows google take over okay not
you google's taking over and they're the
ones setting the bid amounts
automatically and it's gonna be based on
criteria and some of that criteria is
gonna be centered around conversions so
if google bids on your behalf
automatically basically what they're
doing is they're collecting data on the
behavior of your ads and so if your ad
is likely to get the click or conversion
then google is going to set the bid
amount so you can win that auction in
order to get the click or the conversion
so
there are different types of bidding
strategies but remember you have to
align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people to click on your ad and go to
your website then you're going to have
an automated bidding strategy of
maximize clicks that aligns with your
campaign strategy so this strategy
automatically sets your bids to help to
get as many clicks as possible within
your budget so google is going to do its
best based on historical performance of
the campaign to generate traffic to your
site that's the goal that's the biz
strategy okay let's take a look at some
others so hey the goal of our strategy
campaign is to increase visibility so
that's an easy one remember cost per
impressions hey we want to maximize how
many people look at our ads okay so
target impression share so this bidding
strategy allows your bids to show at the
top of the page okay so you're getting
the impression so people are able to
look at your ad okay so you're telling
google hey i want to be shown at least
50 percent of the time when somebody
types in a keyword that i'm bidding on
so they're going to make sure
that they meet your target impression
share 50 so they're going to set your
bids automatically to make sure your ad
shows at the top of the page so it's
seen at least 50 percent of the time
that's the goal of the campaign and
that's the bidding strategy goal we set
up a campaign to drive conversions so
there are a couple bidding strategies
against conversions so target cpa so
this strategy sets a search or display
bid to get as many conversions as
possible but there's a caveat here cost
per acquisition is what cpa stands for
so we're trying to get as many
conversions as possible but at a certain
cost for example if i'm selling t-shirts
for ten dollars do i want to pay twenty
dollars cpa for every sale do i wanna
pay google twenty dollars now i'd be
losing money i'd be out of business okay
so if i'm selling t-shirts for ten
dollars on my website i'm probably gonna
put the cpa about two dollars or three
dollars again depending on my cost of
goods so if i factor in my cost of goods
i'm trying to make a profit then i'm
going to tell google look i'm trying to
get some sales but i don't want to lose
money getting the sale so you're going
to put in a threshold and that threshold
is your target cpa and so google is
going to automatically bid and win the
auction for keywords when they feel
those keywords can get you a target cpa
that you put in for example two dollars
okay so the goal of our campaign is to
meet a target return on ad spend meaning
return on advertising spend meaning
we're getting more revenue than we're
spending that ratio needs to be positive
so google is going to help us again
adjust our bids to make sure that our
return on advertising spend meets our
criteria so we could put a roas as 100
200 etc and google's going to adjust our
bids accordingly based on the keyword
that they think will meet that criteria
of 100 or 200 so that's target return on
advertising spend and that's there to
see if google can help you generate a
profit so we have another campaign set
up we're trying to get more conversions
we have a budget we want to spend the
budget but we all we want to get
conversions so this is a giving the
bidding strategy here would be maximized
conversions so this strategy sets bids
like all the others it automatically is
going to adjust your bid that is google
it's going to adjust the bid to help you
win the auction based on historical
performance so if a keyword and
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe google's
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question that you're going to get if an
interview asks you this question this is
what google ads is all about quality
score so what is quality score so simply
put quality score is a score between 1
and 10 given every keyword you've been
on and basically between 1 and 10 and
space google's giving you the score the
quality score of that keyword and so how
does google come up with that score
between 1 and 10 well there's three main
factors here one is expected
click-through rate the second is ad
relevance and the third is landing page
experience so obviously a higher quality
score the better off you are okay a low
quality score it's not going to bode
well for you and so if you have a low
quality score google actually
will tell you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and i will tell you this
if i were to divide them up into thirds
click-through rate expected
click-through rate is more important
than the other two so that's about
two-thirds of quality score and expected
click-through rate is basically google
saying look other advertisers have bid
on this keyword and their click-through
rate has been historically around say
for example three percent so if you
can't get three percent then your
quality score is going to suffer ad
relevance is simply does the ad or is
the ad relevant to the keyword you're
bidding on likewise for the landing page
but the landing page experience a little
bit more subjective because the landing
page has to load well fast no pop-ups no
a lot of external links nothing spammy
no ads being served up so a lot of
factors in landing page experience
google wants to make sure somebody
clicks on your ad that they're gonna
have a good experience when they land on
that page and so
quality score is so key here it is very
key because if you don't have a good
quality score the repercussion means
you're going to have to bid higher
because quality score times bid
equals ad rank so for every auction
whoever has the highest ad rank is going
to be at the top of google search
results so if you have a low quality
score let's just say one and you're
bidding four dollars on that keyword
then your ad rank is four one times four
is four so you gotta keep that in mind
because other advertisers could have a
higher ad rank or better quality scores
for that keyword so again expect to
click rate this just shows how likely it
is that your ads will get clicked when
shown for a particular keyword google
expects a certain number here you should
always try to achieve the highest
click-through rate possible and
click-through rate is simply how many
times your ad was seen versus how many
times it was clicked that's all
click-through rate is clicks divided by
impressions so you should always try to
achieve the highest click-through rate
possible that will avoid getting a low
quality score add relevance so add
relevance simply means how relevant is
your keyword to the ad okay so if you're
bidding on red adidas running shoes then
make sure your ad discusses and mentions
multiple times naturally red adidas
running shoes okay and remember with
those text ads you have three headlines
you have two description lines of up to
90 characters you have side extensions
okay you have path one and path two that
meaning you can add additional keywords
to the end of a url so you have lots of
opportunities to make sure the ad is
relevant to the keyword and then landing
page experience again this is a little
subjective but hey google is going to
use landing page experience to estimate
how relevant and useful your website's
landing page will be to people who not
only click on your web but land on that
page so does that page load fast does it
have any unnecessary pop-ups does it
does it have some quirky external links
that looks spammy okay you got to take
all these things into consideration and
think about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the hard marks of a good ppc
landing page so going back to landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad they go to
landing page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and powerful
headline should include that key word
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know compliment the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough white space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these pages via mobile so you
gotta take that in consideration as well
so cramming your pages full of content
videos and images is probably not going
to bode well so make sure there's
breathing room for people to read
understand and react and those are
hallmarks of a good ppc landing page
some other factors here adding trust
indicators like
some statistical evidence meaning how
many people downloaded your app you can
always have testimonials you know
third-party sales of approval like
better business bureau you know privacy
policy links help okay so you want to
add some things in there that's going to
you know give you credibility having a
properly designed lead capture form to
collect visitors information is always
helpful if you're trying to get that
conversion then have a lead form make it
simple don't have a lead form with 20
forms or fields you know have a simple
name email address make the phone number
optional and have one feel that they can
type in specific information and then
last but certainly not least have a good
call to action so make sure that call to
action aligns with what you're trying to
do again selling those red adidas
running shoes if they're on sale then
you know make sure the call to action
aligns with that sale you can always say
you have 20 off for the next two days or
you know 10 off if you purchase today so
have some good strong call to action
okay let's turn our attention to email
marketing so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
gonna be asked some questions that are
going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails we all
check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes receive emails
from friends sometimes we receive emails
where we're working or previously worked
so most people have an understanding of
email however as a marketer there's a
little bit of a different twist to it so
we have to understand the intricacies of
how email marketing works so you're
going to be asked some questions and
really the first question here is what's
the difference between a hard and a soft
balance email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're gonna get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so
for example the inbox is full or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so now
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so
next question here what would you do to
improve the click-through rate of your
email so click-through rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high
click-through rate so remember emails
are going to people who likely signed up
to receive your email and even if they
are expecting an email or they're not
expecting an email you still want to
follow some of these best practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line something that people are going to
notice take note of or take an interest
in and say hey what's this all about
that's pretty interesting and open the
email so use preview text effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links so
put some strong call to action in there
and that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you can send
out the same email twice except one
segment is going to say get one version
of the email the other segment is going
to get another version of the email and
what are the different versions maybe
the subject line so the subject line is
different on version a versus version b
or maybe the call to action is different
so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see which
segment or which version got the most
clicks okay so next question here is how
to inform your customers about company
news and establish a relationship with
your target audience okay so again how
do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company and how
are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email well newsletters
are always the best answer here so
somebody signs up for your email let's
just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey
you know if it's a software maybe hey
we've got upcoming updates to our
software make sure you go to the website
and get the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 percent promotional
so remember you're sending out a
newsletter to people who likely signed
up so you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so
make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products to
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real life example because i used to
work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light
blues you know it wasn't black or dark
red or anything that's going to be you
know heavy we knew who our audience was
and we designed the template accordingly
and of course using compelling images so
for selling baby products you're going
to put baby product images in there i
mean it's common sense but you'd be
surprised you gotta pick and choose your
images carefully especially if you're
sending to an international audience
because images can be misconstrued and
just like we mentioned with the
click-through rate you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
gonna have to know what these are so we
already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who bounced it
whether it's a soft bounce a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so
if you have let's just say
20 people opened the email and you sent
it to 100 people then and you had nobody
balanced then it would be a 20 open rate
okay click-through rate again pop quiz
it's just how many people actually
clicked on any of the links in your
email and that's just divided by the
number of emails you've sent out a
response rate okay so response rate is
the percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on the link of your email
campaign and actually completed an
action so what is that action well it
could be downloading something watching
something purchasing something so that's
the response rate similar to conversion
rate if you're working in a digital
marketing channel and you're driving
traffic to the site you want that
traffic to do something well it's no
different in email marketing we want
people to take action we're just going
to divide that by the number of emails
delivered and that gives you your
response rate so let's just say you did
send in 100 emails you did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on a purchase well you'd
have a one percent response rate and
then a forward rate simply the forward
rate refers to the rate at which your
subscribers share your email uh with
others friends family etc and you may
have that as a call to action in your
email in fact that's a best practice so
it's just the number of clicks on a
share divided by the total number of
delivered emails and you're going to
multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at question 25 here
how do we capture inactive customers
what you want to do here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification opt for
subject lines like we have been missing
you or did we do something wrong you
want to run a poll or a competition and
re-engage with your subscribers again
trying to get people involved these
first three are all about getting people
involved so personalize your emails talk
to that person as if hey look i haven't
heard from you in a while how about
coming back and taking a look at our new
products just as you would a friend say
design always matters especially knowing
that you're talking to customers who
haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience somebody who's
inactive so you want to have the right
design the right message the right
subject line that fits with that
customers and activity so you want to
try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so 26 so what
are the different ways to segment buyer
personas so again when we talk about
segmentation we're talking about taking
a smaller piece the entire pie so what's
one way to break up that pie if you will
by geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey if we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand
where your audience lives you also have
demographic segmentation and this is
simply just age education income gender
you know where people work okay
nationality anything that's going to
identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging then you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior
and decide how you want to break out
your emails by behavior and this is a
really good way if you're not even sure
who your audience is or where they live
and how old they are you could certainly
break out your audience by behavior
because you know who these people are
based on what they've done previously
because you're gonna track that
information with analytics so you know
one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list 27 how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click-through rate correctly
kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment below but
let's just say give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following if i
had an audience between 20 and 30 years
old that were female and the product
were sandals okay what would some of
your subject lines be so i'm going to
give you a minute to think about that
and put it in the comment section below
now remember this is an interview based
question so you're going to have to
think on the spot i'm going to give you
a minute but if somebody presented that
to you in an interview you need to be
able to you know react fairly quickly
and come up with some really attractive
subject lines here okay so here you go
here's another one uh so give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for 20 to 30 females for
footwear so you got friday sale coming
up buy branded sandals at the lowest
price okay so i like this one because
it's got a strong call to action buy
here you go this is even better because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't beat free
anything including shipping and if it's
50 off i mean these are key things so
you're putting the promotion and
percentage off all in the subject line
so that's really going to grab
somebody's attention weekend sale for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what does a be testing and
give some examples of a b testing okay
so we talked a little bit about a b
testing with subject lines so simply a b
testing when it comes to email marketing
it's just a method to analyze which of
the two email campaign strategies is
most effective all right you know you're
going to do it based on open rate you
can do it by saying click rate you can
do it based on response rate and
remember you're putting one version of
the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content call to action
whatever so that's ideally what you're
trying to do you're trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for email for a b testing and
email marketing what's going to work and
i would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is gonna work okay so if you're testing
offers then obviously that's gonna be
response rate if you're testing ctas and
that's gonna be click-through rate if
you're testing subject lines that's
going to be open rate so you want to be
able to test different elements of the
email to figure out what works and what
doesn't work okay so how to prevent
email from getting into spam so if
you're an email marketer this is your
worst nightmare you don't want your
emails to get spammed so that doesn't
bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like mailchimp or
constant contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you're if
you know who you're talking to and you
have a cool subject line that's going to
get somebody to react and open and
that's going to prevent somebody from
spamming your email okay you can always
customize your from to make it look like
it's coming from in this case rob
sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so get people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why you sending this to me
i don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject line
is the most probably the most important
element in email marketing so we talked
about that little pop quiz with the
sandals targeting 20 to 30 year old
women you know to me i like the subject
line with the 50 off so that was a
number in the subject line so people can
actually see hey wow i get a whole 50
percent that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
other subject lines had an emoji so
don't be afraid to include emojis in
there for example when i send out emails
using you know during the spring you
might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring winter's over so
personalize the subject lines remember
that goes with segmenting so if you know
who your audience is your subject lines
can be a little bit more personal okay
so off for title case subject lines okay
so instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just set yourself up for better
performance okay let's turn our
attention from email marketing to social
media marketing one of the interesting
channels hot trend channel a lot of
people want to get into social media
marketing a lot of jobs available but
you have to know what you're doing so
let's get into it uh and here's some
questions you might be uh asked in an
interview related to
social media marketing social media
marketing is very interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post
sharing liking engaging commenting i
mean a lot of things going on in social
media so some of it is going to probably
be good most of it's probably going to
be good but every once in a while you're
going to get a negative comment so
you're probably going to be asked this
question how do you respond to negative
comments well very simple you got to be
quick to acknowledge okay don't sit on
it you know don't waste time
him and hot how you're going to respond
you really have to acknowledge the
comment and start the process of
constructive engagement to turn the
negative experience into a positive one
so let me just expand on that for just a
second we know you like your brand we
know you like your product we know
you're very proud we get that i'm proud
i like to defend sometimes my beliefs
however you gotta put that aside when it
comes to social media why because
everybody is watching you and everybody
can read what you write so you the
spotlight is on you not necessarily the
consumer the customer who wrote the
negative comment so you really have to
be cognizant here and conscientious of
what you post in response so be quick
but be constructive because you want to
turn that negative into a positive
that's really what it's starting with so
how do you do that well how do you be
constructive well see it from the
customer's point of view take off your
ownership hat if you will your manager
hat and put on the customer's hat always
look at something from somebody else's
perspective try to understand why that
person wrote that negative comment and
ask yourself how you can make it right
so if you're the customer and you are
your customer when you go to the store
and buy food you're the customer when
you go to the store and buy clothes when
you buy a car you're the customer so ask
yourself what you can do to make it
right why you're thinking in the
customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so
really because everybody's looking at
you waiting to see how you respond and
remember this customer that wrote the
negative comment can certainly share
your comments to the world so you got to
be really really careful i mean how many
times have we seen on youtube you know
poor customer experience going viral on
on via video so you just gotta really be
careful here so take it out of the
spotlight so offer to resolve the
customers problems in an appropriate
forum offer up your phone number an
email give them a link to a feedback
form or get their email or phone number
and call them these are the best ways to
really bend this into a more positive
experience for the customer i mean at
the end of the day could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mall hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it and see more
than what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done so here's a good
example spotify you can see the spotify
ad here with ed sharon spotify mind the
search and playlist data of its user
base to develop a thematic branded ad
experience on billboards in 18 markets
around the world first of all let's just
take this and break it down and sharing
is popular you can see here be as loving
as the person who put 48 ed sheeran
songs on their i love gingers playlist
so
messaging is everything okay and then
you can see what spotify did they mine
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
gotta understand your audience okay then
they use that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy i'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're spotify you're gonna pick
something hot and trendy to get people
to react and so to me this seems like
just on the surface a very successful
social media campaign here's some other
things uh you can see these ads were
featured on the sides of buildings
subway platforms along busy streets so
it wasn't just digital per se i mean
they really went full bore on the
billboards and those billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily edge
sharing per se but you know they had
some good messaging and gr enjoy green
light at every red light that's pretty
cool i guess if you're stuck in traffic
in the middle of a city less fake news
more fake magic so they really took and
honed in the type of music put some good
messaging behind it and really put it
out there so it doesn't always
necessarily have to you know necessarily
be digital per se but they what they did
was they did post this on the sides of
buildings and subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're a social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straight up
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on facebook you
know you can do single image ads most of
us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads i mean you got
all sorts of a variety of different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know has
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or link to your
website
or your facebook page and a strong call
to action okay so facebook has that
built into their ad platform okay so the
ad images need to be 1200 by 628 pixels
it's a pretty nice size image
multi-product ads so multi-product ads
are
represented in carousel form so
basically it allows you the end user to
view the range of products just by
scrolling and notice each one of these
products has a call to action so here
you can see simply learn offering up all
the different courses they have to offer
so if you have a customer that has
multiple products this is probably the
way you want to go so video ads are very
popular on facebook so video ads usually
range from a few seconds all the way up
to 120 minutes and again video is very
engaging if you have video use the video
okay because they receive about 10 to 30
more views than other forms of ads okay
who doesn't like engaging with video
pretty simple you have lead ads so lead
ads allow you to obtain user details
like name phone number email right in
facebook's environment so it allows you
to collect information right then and
there so lead ads can be effective if
you're trying to get people to sign up
for something slideshow so we looked at
those multi-product ads where you had
the carousel slideshow simply just
allows you to rotate different creative
with nice imagery so the key here is
nice imagery okay you want to put your
best foot forward choose the right
imagery just like going back to the
email marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on facebook so collection
x ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so i would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several of their
products at once okay again simply learn
has a lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ads works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got ppc certification
seo certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together
so lo and behold collection ads offers
the best option here so pay attention
those different ad formats on facebook
okay next question how can you use the
holiday season for social media
marketing well this is a nice segue from
the previous question because you know
you have on facebook all these different
ad types so you can change your ad
placements to ones lesser used by other
advertisements you can also set up clear
simple and compelling offers for your
users the holiday season you're likely
going to have some sales and again make
sure your images have under 20
of text okay that's a standard across
the board but again you want to have
nice imagery so think about all those
different ad formats on facebook think
about the holiday season and how you can
accentuate your ads here okay i'm
thinking video here i'm thinking a
promotion in the video i'm thinking a
collection ad where you can run
different products maybe with a
promotion with some nice imagery during
the holiday season so you definitely
have a plethora of options not just on
facebook but across social media for the
holidays because normally you're going
to have promotions some other things you
can do to
really maximize the holiday season for
social media and that's make
advertisements emotionally resonate with
your audience the holiday season is a
time really where you reflect on the air
you get together with friends and family
and it's religious and you know it's a
feel good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic an
uptick in eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money sake
so on facebook it's a cost per click
model so you don't want to be generating
clicks without seeing any results so go
ahead and pay attention maximize those
ads that are performing and get rid of
the ones that aren't okay and then
connect the holiday with your products
or services so again think about which
ones you're going to accentuate which
ones you're going to make more prominent
during the holiday season again thinking
back to the facebook ad types i'm
thinking carouseller collection ads if
you can really pump up some of your
products and have a nice promotion with
them you can run some nice collection
ads on facebook okay moving on to the
next question so somebody may ask you
hey how do you make content go viral
okay i always wondered that myself how
does content go viral it's a great
question so really you're not in
necessarily in control
but you can certainly do some things to
make it more appealing for the end user
to go ahead and share it i mean that's
what going viral is right a lot of
people sharing it because the more
people that share the more people are
going to look and find it just as
enticing and they're going to turn
around and share it so how do you start
that process really is what it comes
down to well create short form content
short form content is more likely to go
viral in other words a 10 minute video
is probably not going to resonate with
somebody something cute funny
interesting unique out of this world in
15 30 seconds is probably gonna go viral
so what does that mean make the visual
content like images and video it works
better than bodies of text so make sure
those images and video are really
compelling and then run giveaways to
draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always incentivize your users with a
giveaway or some type of promotion
that's going to maybe pique somebody's
interest you know share it with a
hundred friends and get 10 off as an
example so these are some of the things
you can do to make it go viral of course
if you're trying to get something to go
viral you definitely want to monitor
behavior and then tweak once you figure
out how it's performing okay you may
have chosen the wrong images you may
have the wrong promotion you may find
that the contents a little bit longer
than you probably like and you may want
to cut it down some other things you
could do here is use some trending
hashtags and topics on your post so ride
that wave if you will for any surfers in
the audience hey two people can ride the
same wave so if you got a trending
hashtag use that hashtag with that video
or post you can always ask users to
interact okay so you can always ask them
to like or share especially if they're
their audience because when somebody
actually shares it that means they're
sharing it with somebody else who also
has an audience so that's a quick way to
get the ball going so to speak about
bouncing okay so next question which
industries perform better with different
platforms great question there's a lot
of different social media platforms you
got your most popular ones all the way
down to your least popular ones i mean
let's face it social media platforms are
also geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
united states than say india or russia
and vice versa we know china has a lot
of different social media platforms that
most americans in the united states
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you got to also think about industry
here so generally facebook it's usually
food and beverage news and media
e-commerce those are the types of
industries that you might tend to see on
facebook when we talk about e-commerce
you know it could be clothing it could
be you know restaurant okay selling or
it could be a a food company selling you
know foods and beverages you also have
instagram so instagram tends to be more
beauty food and beverage e-commerce so
when we talk about beauty we're talking
about clothes we're talking about makeup
you know maybe shoes dresses unique
styles i see a lot of that on instagram
and then linkedin for example generally
works with you know for me i look at
linkedin as b2b okay so anything you
know interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
recruiters on linkedin so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the united states you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find i'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comments section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so share your thoughts
and knowledge with the rest of us so
next question how would you measure
social media marketing success of an
organization and this is a likely
question a question you're likely going
to get okay how do you measure success
and that's across the board not just
social but ppc email marketing display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
legion or form submissions anything
where you're gonna get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on facebook and you're running a
lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission do you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot trends it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world of fair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like etc so
engagement metrics vary across different
social media platforms but basically
when it comes to engagement you can
measure it just has to align with the
right strategy you also have awareness
again if you're just simply in it for
brand awareness okay it's all about how
many people are actually looking at it
the total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to websites
by clicks or shares so it doesn't always
have to be about conversion or
engagement it can simply hey we want to
drive traffic to the website it's at 37
what are some things to focus on when
advertising on twitter okay you can
advertise on twitter whether you knew
that or not now you know twitter is a
platform where you can pay for
advertising so
what do you want to focus on when you do
advertise on twitter well you want to
emphasize urgency to make sure users
take immediate action you want to
express discounts and percentages why
well because you're limited in what you
can say on twitter you want to avoid
using hashtags that don't pertain to
your brand and product i know that may
sound like common sense but remember
you're advertising in here so you got to
be really really really careful because
you're paying you're paying for somebody
to either look at that ad or click on
that ad so some other things you want to
keep focus on is your ad copy it's got
to be short and to the point and then
make sure your ads are mobile friendly
again just like most social media
platforms twitter is no different people
are looking at twitter on their mobile
phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to thank mobile mobile
mobile mobile because most people are
using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via an
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up i want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on twitter
linkedin etc and what you could do is if
you've run other events in the past
create a highlight rail from prior
events you know show people hey your
events are the events you must attend
they're the go-to events because they're
popular they're successful good
attendees usually good attendance and
then some other things you could do here
share behind the screen's visual content
and again you could share pictures of
guest speakers along with your quotes
okay so you want to do everything
possible at your at your disposal
especially on social media to really
pump up the event next question how can
you perform a b testing on your ads so
for those of you that listen intently on
the email marketing part remember a b
testing is key with email marketing what
are we testing in email we're testing
subject lines we're testing layout we're
testing call to action so the same thing
here on social media you want to do
continuous a b testing to figure out
what works and doesn't work it's very
simple the great thing about facebook is
they got an a b test feature built in so
you can certainly test different ads
great thing about facebook i like is
that you can simply start out with an
app by running an a b test you could
simply test the imagery it could be a
male versus a female you could test the
call to action a lot of things you could
test so things you can change are again
color of the elements you could change
the positioning you could change the
audience you're targeting the call to
action i mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the female
tends to work better in the mail then
you know what works in terms of imagery
well take the next step and start honing
it on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like cta
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the a b testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to stay away from
clipart okay so again align your imagery
really is important on social media
don't use some basic cheap clipart you
don't necessarily always have to use
stock imagery either i mean it could be
imagery you took that's very relevant
and unique to your product but if you do
that don't use low resolution pixelated
images use images that are well lit so
decide on the aesthetic you want for
your creative clean and minimal or
colorful and vibrant it really depends
on you know the advertisement what it is
you're trying to promote so some other
things to focus on here to create
attention grabbing ads show images of
people benefiting from your product and
coca-cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a coca-cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke i
don't think i've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself okay
so let's finish up with content
marketing content marketing another big
digital marketing channel a lot of work
out there so if you're going in for an
interview let's review some of the
questions you may get asked okay so
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
gonna read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after they're
done engaging with the good content that
you write okay so some other things to
think about some other components for
good content well credibility so you
know anybody can write but are you
writing about something you know what
you're writing about are you a good
talking point a good expert or have
experience about this content so you
also want to use you know information
from a legitimate source okay so you
don't want to grab something in your and
use it in your content that's just not
legitimate because it does hurt your
credibility and the organization's
credibility and then also originality i
mean write something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study and create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people come back for more they know
when you're going to post they're going
to be waiting for it and if it's every
tuesday morning 8 o'clock hey post it
tuesday morning 8 o'clock your users
will get used to that schedule and it
does help build up your following it
does help help build up your community
and in the end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship and then having a content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up whether it be a blog post
uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time especially
if you're going to work in a new company
so let's say writing content you
definitely want to have a content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time to efficiently plan this
is a new company you're going to start
working at you want to understand who
this company is what they've done in the
past what you haven't done and what you
want to do okay so all of that helps you
plan and prepare and it saves you the
time and effort and hassle down the road
and then at the end of the day you want
to be able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh and
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
twitter if you're putting a content
calendar in
it together for twitter well you don't
want to have the same tweets every other
day so it does ensure that you're
getting tweets out there that are fresh
that are new that are different and
again figure out what works a content
counter makes it easier to measure
results and optimize performance so you
always want to you know maybe put some
metrics in with your content calendar so
you can see side by side content
historically that is performed content
that is not performed okay so next
question you may get what type of
content works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so
you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay a post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you can
certainly send out follow-up emails and
you can do blog round-ups you know give
people an opportunity to see what
features or updates are happening to the
product okay of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service okay so
if somebody's already purchased and you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complements the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community they're gonna be your
advocates so give them exclusive
discounts and then pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not gonna share that so you're gonna
have people share that information in
other words you can generate content
where hey people can help you out here
and be your advocate okay so how do you
decide what topic and subject to write
on okay well going back to the content
counter that always helps you see what
you put in that content calendar but
there are some other methods you can use
and you could certainly identify your
target audience and not only identify
your target audience but what their
needs are okay so you can write content
based on audience you could certainly do
some research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
cora i always look at cora core is
interesting entertaining informational
people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience i.e street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be you know as humorous as you
would be say on instagram or facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay within the brand what is the
brand's personality how do we want to
talk to our audience and what platform
are we using to talk to our audience how
do you promote your content once it's
live well that's always a good question
hey you doing the the work the putting
in the hard work to create this you know
it could be a video and videos take a
long time it could be an infographic an
ebook okay so send it out via email okay
if you haven't an email list send it out
and let people know this content's there
put a link in the email or or even a
piece or snippet or preview of the
content in the email so you're using the
email to broadcast and encourage people
to you know if it's an ebook get the
rest of the ebook okay you could
certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey i got
i got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
google or facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again you've
done all the work you've put the content
calendar together you got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it social email guest blogging
but you want to determine how it's doing
well depends on the channel really is
what it comes down to so if it's organic
search you want to be able to see if
it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments etc of course
you can always look at analytics and see
how much traffic that blog post is
getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes
you need to define buyer personas to
determine the audience best suited for
your content okay so you're always
writing for an audience and you're going
to market that content for that audience
so you always got to keep that in mind
okay run content audits audits to
determine the best type of content that
can be used in other words how did it
perform what kind of engagement did you
get with the infographic or did that
video really really perform well or do
we want to use you know a blog post next
time around or an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so if they fit a certain age range
or generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay that
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is so with this we have
come to the end of this session on
digital marketing i hope the session was
informative and exciting in case you
have any questions about any of the
topics covered in this session or if you
need the resources used in this session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tushar from the
simply learn team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you